hi i'm aparna sinha welcome to day two
of google cloud next i'll be co-hosting
today alongside ores holdslay and we've
got a really great lineup of new
technology and demos from google cloud
but before we get started i want to
thank you all for taking time out of
your busy week to be here with us
yesterday was an incredible first day at
next thomas and sundar made some amazing
announcements
this week we're releasing over 100 new
products services and programs for you
we're kicking off day two now with this
keynote a cloud built for developers
after this we'll jump right into a live
developer q a where you can ask us
anything
and then tomorrow is community day and
that will be totally dedicated to you
for learning discussions networking and
all kinds of fun
all right
let's get things started by welcoming
orrs
hi orrs hi aparna hi everyone i hope
you're as excited as i am to get started
today and since this is a developer
keynote we'll kick it off with our first
demo right away from google research and
our deepmind colleagues who've been
working on some amazing voice technology
welcome to next twenty one documents
now before you get too impressed by my
language skills i did not actually speak
these words
what you just heard is a custom
text-to-speech model that has trained on
my voice and that can generate synthetic
speech in different languages
and our teams have already started using
this technology to improve our voice
experience for all users that's right
google's project euphonia is already
using custom voice to help people with
atypical speech to communicate and be
better understood
technology like this creates a more
inclusive world
to find out more about this check out
the project euphonia website
custom voice is available today for
select cloud customers we're very
mindful of the potential misuses of this
technology and we're taking great care
to prevent them by reviewing each use
case uniquely
now look around you
every day you see innovation that's
brought to you
by developers like yourself with
persistence and skill
and google has a long tradition of
supporting developers in open source and
elsewhere
for years
you've been using technologies like
kubernetes
firebase tensorflow
go angular grpc many others
and when we built google cloud we built
it for developers and we were inspired
by all the things you've created with it
and our job is quite simply to make it
easier for you to
do what you love
so we focus on making you as productive
as productive as possible with
the least amount of effort and so in
everything we design
we take all the feedback that you're
sharing with us and uh build a cloud
platform that just works
whether that's by natively embedding key
security or sustainability features into
the platform itself or by feature
featuring partner solutions
right within our own console we're
really focused on one goal giving you
the best developer experience
of any cloud provider
google cloud has had tremendous traction
with digital native customers since our
very early days
how have you seen customer and partner
adoption evolve since then
well many of our biggest customers are
cloud natives but we've seen tremendous
adoption by a broad segment of
enterprise customers in traditional
industries as well like entertainment or
financial services for example
major league baseball
which is north america's oldest and most
attended professional sports league is
using google cloud to modernize fan
engagement and to increase operational
efficiency
and equifax
which was founded in 1899 and is one of
the world's largest consumer credit
reporting agencies is transforming
itself from a credit bureau to a next
generation data analytics and technology
company built on google cloud
we've seen a huge shift
essentially every company is becoming a
tech company to increase their
competitiveness and establish leadership
in their industries
developer talent and cloud services are
at the heart of this shift
whether you call that digital
transformation or something else
companies of all sizes are finding that
google cloud is optimized to help make
your data your applications and your
talent more useful and relevant to your
business
exactly and as thomas mentioned
yesterday everyone needs to be thinking
through how they'll fundamentally shift
into a technology company to serve their
customers in the most meaningful ways 10
years from now
and you as developers are key
to making this happen
so organizations ask themselves
do we have
the most cutting-edge technology to
become a leader in our industry and you
the developers are well equipped to
answer this
and we are super focused uh on making
you and your company successful and
there's two areas we focus on to support
your growth first of course making it
easier for developers to get their job
done
second investing in the developer
community so that everyone can learn and
grow from each other
so let's talk about how google cloud is
making it easier for developers to get
their job done
um from our transformational
infrastructure stack to our deep
innovations in data security uh ml
every feature we release starts with
simplifying the developer experience uh
take our open cloud experience for for
example we recently expanded our compute
stack uh to include tau vms that deliver
42 better price performance over any
other comparable solution in the market
with no recompile
and thanks to our zero trust approach to
security google cloud was ranked a
leader in ios platform native security
by forrester well ahead of the
competition
and of course we're focusing also on
managed services that make it easy for
you to deploy scale and manage
kubernetes clusters uh
on the edge or in the cloud and google
cloud has the most complete and most
secure container experience for
developers in fact the 2021 gartner
solution scorecard for google kubernetes
engine gave gke an overall score of 92
again well ahead of the competition
and of course with gke and anthos you
can run these containers anywhere on
premise other clouds on the edge you
know anywhere
so it's fair to say that in the years
since google invented kubernetes
containers have really completely
revolutionized it operations
now recently european filmmakers from
honeypot.io created a documentary on the
history of kubernetes and it will be out
in january 2022 and you are the very
first audience to have a look at the
trailer right now so let's roll that
sounds pretty awesome do i look at you
look at cameron
[Music]
2013 it was clear that cloud was a thing
but most folks were focused on
infrastructure cloud
the dirty secret for a long time is like
you know people who are either building
their own data centers or using colos
there's a huge resource waste
and so at that point
automation tools are all the rave people
are now trying to abstract the way the
servers google was looking for ways to
apply its internal infrastructure
expertise
to the cloud
as we started looking at technologies
like docker we were like impressed by
the strength of what they've
accomplished in solving a very specific
problem
this is going to happen with us or
without us google had to make a bold
move in the cloud space to be the
long-term winner
every big startup i felt like had a
container orchestration project
and half of them were announced at
dockercon 2014.
open source is most successful when it's
played as a positive sum game
[Music]
this is such a great community
yeah absolutely i recognize a lot of the
faces and i can't wait to see the film
uh now let's get back to uh how we're
making it easier for developer uh
for you to build really the leading
technology companies of tomorrow
now kubernetes deployments can involve a
fair bit of manual configuration uh
clusters nodes load balancers yamls etc
but not on google cloud because we offer
you the most automated and secure
kubernetes experience available
with gke autopilot google provisions and
manages the cluster's entire underlying
infrastructure including control plane
node pools or
working nodes and they
that lets you focus on the higher level
services and applications that you're
building
nobody else
offers anything like this
because beyond managing node upgrades gk
autopilot also automatically configures
security features like shielded gke
nodes secure boot and workload identity
and it also implements security best
practices by blocking let's say features
like external ips or legacy
authorization
so
you don't get a toy kubernetes cluster
with gk autopilot you get a
sophisticated cluster that uses the best
practices brought to you by the team
that brought you kubernetes itself
so you're always up to date
and you get the same results as the
experts without having to be an expert
yourself
the pandemic put developers in the
driver's seat and you all drove gka
usage to all-time highs
at the same time we saw explosive growth
in the use of google cloud serverless
offerings especially cloud run and cloud
functions
it's mainly enterprise developers who
have driven this growth
cloud run excels at developer experience
it's earned the highest customer
satisfaction rating among developers as
measured by user research international
cloud run combines the best of both
worlds bringing you serverless and
containers
there's no cluster to set up or
configure so developers are able to
scale seamlessly and securely
under the hood cloud run scales
container instances in isolated
sandboxes any access outside a sandbox
is mediated by network controls or
identity and access management or both
and it isn't just for new apps
cloud run supports traditional workloads
like java spring boot and asp.net
we also recently introduced committed
use discounts to lower the cost at scale
and we've introduced always-on cpu which
enables asynchronous and background
processes to be used on cloud run
so you have all the benefits of
serverless without the restrictions
the theme here is easier more secure
development
especially with remote work
you're absolutely right uh we've been
focusing on remote development for some
time now but the pandemic has certainly
accelerated the shift now what would be
more essential to remote development
than to be able to use the full power of
gcp right from your laptop with zero
local setup
cloud shell editor is a context aware
remote development environment that lets
you develop and manage applications
securely from any browser
it supports languages like go java node
python c-sharp and it comes with an
integrated debugger source control api
explorer
and if you want to test locally on your
laptop it also comes with local
emulators for kubernetes and serverless
apis thanks oars next let me introduce
you to abby kerry she's going to show us
how google cloud makes it easy for you
to securely build modern applications
again right from your laptop hi abby hi
aparna we developers have had a hard
time writing extending deploying and
operating applications but doesn't have
to be difficult
let's start with cloud shell editor it
comes with current versions of your
favorite dev tools like docker mini cube
scaffold and more
there's nothing to download or install
locally tutorials are built into cloud
shell editor which makes it easy to come
up to speed on complex topics like gke
so no more switching between tabs docs
your terminal and your code
this integrated experience is highly
differentiated from other clouds you can
even author your own tutorials and that
allows your organization to share best
practices and onboard new hires faster
another popular feature is kubernetes
yaml authoring assistance
let's say i want to add yaml for a
service to this project i can press
control space
and then find the kubernetes service
snippet
now i can tab through and fill
everything in
i also get completes
and if i happen to make a formatting
mistake i am notified that there's an
issue in real time
now many of you prefer to work locally
in an ide this same yaml authoring
assistance it's also available for vs
code and intellij via the cloud code
plugin
cloud code has built-in support for both
cloud run and kubernetes
in fact if you're using cloud run or
functions you don't need to know docker
you can build and deploy your app with
just one command because cloud code or
because cod build is integrated under
the hood
this is an application with no docker
file
with the new gcloud run deploy command
all i have to do is provide a name for
my service
and then let it know where my source
code lives which is this current
directory
and we're deploying
so nice
and thanks to this ease of use 98
percent of users deploy an application
to cloud run on their first try in less
than five minutes
i just showed source code deploys the
cloud run but there are more ways google
cloud has made deployment easier and
more secure
first i can scan my build container
images to check for vulnerabilities
i've already run an on-demand scan on
one of my images using gcloud artifacts
docker images scan
now i can copy the id of my scan and
then view my image's vulnerabilities
with the list vulnerabilities command
and then once that's finished a severity
level is assigned to each vulnerability
to help you prioritize that's super
important it's really helpful in
addressing security concerns earlier in
the software development life cycle
but now what if your build pipeline is
compromised for that i can enable binary
authorization on my deployed cloud run
services this way only trusted container
images are deployed to production
binary authorization is truly unique in
the industry it enables you to put
proactive security measures in place to
reduce software supply chain attack risk
by blocking deployments that violate
policy
and speaking of deploying we're making
it seamless for you to do ci cds
securely
you can take advantage of serverless
build environments within your own
private network with cloud-build private
pools and for advanced cd we have google
cloud deploy which allows you to create
custom delivery pipelines for your
specific use case and needs that is so
cool
well a real application connects to many
supporting cloud services so abby can
you show us an example of how we make
these integrations easier sure when
creating a cloud function it's easy to
integrate with seeker manager
first
create a secret that stores your api key
which i've already done
now i can either mount it as a volume or
expose it as an environment variable
i'll mount it as a volume and then i'll
name my mount path
this will always point to the latest
version of my secret
and now i can securely reference this
api key from my source code this
abstraction enables portability and a
better local development experience
cloudrun also integrates with secret
manager
to make it easier to do the right thing
and not put sensitive data in source i
love that so much
okay so now you've written your app
you've deployed your app and you've
connected your app to other google cloud
resources what's next operating your app
in production
with cloud ops you get one integrated
view for your alerts
events
metrics
and logs
no more jumping around multiple tools as
you try to understand what went wrong
that was so awesome abby thank you for
sharing this with us thanks aparna
in each of these instances we've done
the integration work for you because the
more work we put into this the less work
you have to do
and this principle applies to security
as well we've put a lot of energy into
building security natively into
everything we do so that you can
innovate with assurance
both dke and cloud run benefit from the
security fixes we implement before
vulnerabilities are exposed just think
about the famous vulnerability uncovered
in how kubernetes was handling proxy
requests
we found it we coordinated and
communicated the disclosure we fixed it
for the entire kubernetes community and
we patched all our products before any
customers were impacted
more recently cyber threats have shifted
the focus towards the software supply
chain
that's right malicious actors are trying
to compromise the software supply chain
uh from bad code's emission to bypassing
the cicd pipeline altogether and to help
solve this problems we proposed an
industry standard
called salsa
it's a security framework that provides
common criteria for increasing levels of
software security through automation and
through cryptographic signing at each
stage of the software supply chain
and that makes it uh
possible but not necessarily easy and so
making it easy for developers to ensure
security is
super important and that's why we're
focusing on building the security right
into the developer tool chain
anticipating and preventing issues ahead
of time not when you're most at risk
so for example cloud build are service
that lets you build test and deploy
across multiple environments such as vms
serverless kubernetes or firebase now
offers salsa level one compliance by
default
because cloud build gives you verifiable
build provenance so this provenance lets
you trace a binary to the source code
that it was built from to prevent
tampering and to prove that the code
that you think you're running actually
is the code you are running
cloud build is the first and only ci cd
service to offer this capability but we
go beyond that as you've seen
build integrity
automatically generates digital
signatures which can then be validated
before deployment by binary
authorization that's another google
cloud first
and so without you needing to do
anything
we prevent anyone in your organization
from deploying code that has not been
built by your legitimate build system
now ensuring security post deployment is
equally critical on gcp you can enable
continuous scanning and you can use our
service mesh to embrace a zero trust uh
security model and automatically and
declaratively secure your services and
the communication so you can manage
authentication authorization and
encryption between services with little
or no changes to the applications
themselves
let me say that again
with little to no changes to the
applications themselves
so that means that these security
improvements help secure not just new
code but also existing binaries so you
can use them for any application that
you're migrating to the cloud
both and service mesh and now cloud
build hybrid are available across google
cloud and your on-premise environment
and they work with
vpc service controls and vpc peering to
automate the developer security for your
enterprise
no other cloud provider protects your
software supply chain to this level
because
we started working on software supply
chain security long before it was in
headlines and so by choosing tcp you
benefit from this leading edge focus on
security
whether we're building foundational open
source technologies like kubernetes or
istio or turning them into fully managed
services like gke and antho service mesh
our goal is always to reduce complexity
for our users
by helping create these industry
standards we can provide safer and
simpler services for you the developer
and that's exactly our approach to
securing the software supply chain we've
co-founded the open source security
foundation with other technology leaders
to create security standards for open
source software
and we're starting to bring products to
market like open source insights which
provides you a complete transitive
dependency graph for many open source
packages
now
let's turn back to oris to hear why
google cloud is best positioned to
support you in becoming a technology
leader in your industry using data as a
core asset
thanks yeah so far we've been talking
about developing and managing code
but data is at the heart of many
enterprises
so we also have the leading data cloud
products in the industry
designed for optimal performance and
reliability for applications of all
sizes while scaling to immense
escape capacity
now
let's start with databases when it comes
to databases every cloud gives you
choices
they offer sql databases which are great
but unfortunately don't scale
and of course nosql databases which do
scale but unfortunately are not sql
only google cloud gives you a third
choice with spanner
because spanner is sql and in fact it
just got a postgres interface
but it scales horizontally and it can
literally handle a billion requests per
second
nobody else has a scalable sql system so
it's no wonder we're seeing huge
adoption
now on the data warehouse side we have
of course the leading cloud data
warehouse with bigquery hundreds of
customers are using bigquery
at petabyte scale today petabyte each
and you can run of course bigquery omni
on aws or azure
on top of that open source systems for
data lake processing like flank spark
and beam run natively on google cloud in
a simpler and more cost effective way
than in other environments uh in fact
you can realize a 57 percent lower tcl
compared to on-premise data leaks for
data science projects
now on top of that savings our data
cloud also includes the world's first
and only auto scaling and serverless
spark service
and finally google has deep partnerships
with leading data-driven companies
including databricks confluent mongodb
varies labs and many others
and so together we help customers access
an open platform that powers analytics
at scale yet is easy to use
our partner community is central to the
health of our cloud business
and we're especially excited about the
innovation coming from our data cloud
partnerships together we've optimized
our infrastructure for performance and
efficiency to give our partners that
extra edge when they run on google cloud
one of our leading data partners is
mongodb
and we have their ceo dave iteria here
with us today
welcome dave
hi everyone happy to be here
dave one of the trends we're seeing in
our enterprise customer base is that
they are now competing for leadership
positions in their industry by becoming
technology companies
how would you say
google cloud and mongodb working
together can help these customers
achieve that transition
well aparna the companies who are in the
leadership positions in their industries
are those who have built their
competitive advantage using software and
data to transform their business
and the key word here is build you can't
buy a competitive advantage you have to
build it this means you need to enable
your developers to innovate as quickly
as possible whether it's building new
software to seize new opportunities or
to respond to new threats
mongodb and google cloud deeply
understand this developers choose
mongodb on google cloud because we give
them the tools they need to be as
productive as possible
including having our services available
in the google cloud console for easy
discovery and deployment today mongodb
atlas runs in 24 google regions across
the world with deep technical
integrations with google's analytic and
ai tools
this enables our customers to innovate
quickly and emerge as leaders in their
industries as a result we're seeing
explosive growth of customers embracing
the true value of our partnership that's
incredible
so when you think about the development
teams at these new customers what's the
biggest challenge that you're helping
them solve
when you talk to development teams you
find that they spend the most amount of
their time trying to work with data as
serving relevant data at the right time
to the right audience is critical to
building any application
unfortunately
relational databases are not designed
for the way developers think or code nor
are they designed for scale fault
tolerance
or
resilience consequently development
teams find it hard to move fast using
relational databases
mongodb is designed to address this
problem we make it very easy for
developers to work with data and we're
able to address the most demanding
requirements for performance scale and
fault tolerance
the partnership with mongodb and google
cloud enables developers around the
world to easily build modern software
applications to address their needs of
today and tomorrow
that's terrific thank you so much for
being here with us today
thank you for having me
and yes thanks dave for joining us um
now there's lots of ways developers can
improve their productivity um automate
tasks that are repetitive master the
command line use the best tools that
make your life easier or reuse other
people's code you know just to name a
few and another great way to accelerate
your productivity is with building
blocks or templates or fully managed
services in areas like machine learning
because on
google cloud you don't have to be an
expert to build smart applications with
uh new services like verdict's ai you
can build deploy and scale more
effective ai models quickly
so that lets you deliver the insights to
your organization that will help them
create more personalized customer
experiences around more efficient
processes and take that leadership
position in your industry
so with that let's go to our next live
demo
joining me today is anusha vastava she's
going to show us how these breakthroughs
in ai are advancing cloud adoption and
redefining the world of document
processing
hi anu hey aparna
we all know how to work with data when
it's in a structured format like in a
database some json csv files or just
variables in my code right
but what about
unstructured data
many of the world's business processes
start include or end with a document
but these documents can be difficult to
process
think about all the ways you could
enhance your application if you could
just unlock that data
this is where google cloud document ai
comes in
doc ai is a platform that has solutions
and tooling for automating your
workflows backed by machine learning
we've bundled together some of google's
flagship ai technology such as computer
vision ocr natural language
understanding and even google's
expertise and building knowledge graphs
all to provide you with a simple yet
powerful way to build applications that
better understand unstructured data
let's go see a demo of doc ai in action
so here we have a receipt i was buying
some office supplies since we are
unfortunately not back in the office yet
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually upload this into the dock ai
platform
so in our cloud console we have the dock
ai platform where we have built-in
preview mechanisms so you can test out
your documents
so this is going to an endpoint which
has a specialized model we have
specifically trained on a variety of
expenses google maintains and improves
the models for you
wait a minute
i hope this is not with my data
absolutely not we never use your data to
train our models your data is only used
to serve your request
so let's take a look at the data
extracted
i've seen this before next you're going
to tell me that you're going to automate
my expenses
i knew you would say that this is the
canonical demo use case right but have
you ever seen it like this
take a look at this field that i'm
highlighting the supplier address
this address isn't present anywhere in
the document wow where did that come
from this is only possible with google's
document ai the secret sauce here is
that the knowledge graph is able to not
only give you back the original text
from document but it's going to enrich
your response akin to what you'd see in
a search
but as part of your api response wow
that's really great
and it's not just this we have several
specialized models for many more
document types of much higher complexity
let's take a look at this payslip
so i ran this earlier and we're looking
at the preview output again you can see
that we have some keys we have some
fields you can see enrichment on the
employer name and the address
once your data is in a schematized
format meaning that we know for every
document of a certain doctype there are
common important pieces of information
so what we did is we predefined a set of
keys so what we do is with your
extracted data we merge your data to
these predefined keys so it's much
easier to work with than raw ocr
so once it's in a schematized format
it's easier to pass on to a downstream
service or maybe you're using something
for analytics like bigquery or looker
that makes sense but what about ensuring
accuracy and also do you have
multi-language support we know that with
important documents such as these you
can't afford any missteps when it comes
to accuracy so that's why doc ai
provides a human in the loop
configuration to trigger on confidence
scores so either for specific keys or on
the entire document itself and as for
translation we support over 100
languages such as spanish japanese
arabic no other solution on the market
supports such a wide array of languages
human in the loop translation and
knowledge graph capabilities that can be
applied to a wide variety of documents
this seems super useful
of course the next big question is can
it be applied to big bulky complex
documents like like business contracts
let's take a look
so here i read a contract earlier this
morning
you can see that there are typical
things you'd find in any contract there
are some
document names the parties involved some
dates and like with every easy to read
contract being sarcastic here
there is an expiration term so this
expiration date actually isn't present
anywhere in the document and it's
actually not easy to figure out it's not
in an easily parsable format shocker
google's contract processor is able to
figure out this state value by
understanding signals found across the
entire document
wow
well anu before you go can you tell our
awesome developers how they can get
started with doc ai absolutely so i know
we covered a lot at just breakneck
speeds so check out the breakout
sessions on doc ai to dive deeper you
can also check out the documentation for
codelabs and quickstarts we have client
libraries and all of your favorite
languages such as python node.js my
personal favorite is java but it's an
api so you can really use this with
whatever platform or framework you're
already using
we are thrilled and look forward to see
how you use google doc ai to power your
applications
that was amazing can i have a high five
yeah
thank you anu i loved every part of it
thank you for having me
another area that google has invested in
deeply and that's becoming more
important to more companies is
sustainability
many cloud providers have a vision for
us in sustainable future and many aim to
have uh to match their electricity
consumption with 100
renewable energy by 2025 or 2030.
we accomplished a 100 renewable energy
in 2017 so we're the only hyperscale
cloud to do this today
and all that with data centers that are
twice as efficient as the average data
center
this past week sunder talked about
google's goal to enable over a billion
users to live and work more sustainably
by next year
to reach goals like this and those
outlined in climate pledges made by more
organizations every day
we rely on developers like you to do
something about it
but we also know that it's difficult
that's right one of the biggest
challenges that companies face is that
they lack the tools to account for
environmental costs and to help
developers address this for their
organizations we built sustainability
tools directly into google cloud
with google cloud carbon footprint you
have access to the energy related
emissions data that you need for
external carbon disclosures in just one
click
now you won't need this calculator if
you just want to report the net carbon
footprint of your workload on tcp
because on gcp it's always zero
we also have our region picker where you
can choose the data center region with
the lowest gross carbon cost right now
of course again your net impact is zero
no matter what region you pick but this
tool lets you help go one step further
to become carbon free
not just carbon neutral
now that's actually a tool that i can't
wait to deprecate in 2030 or so because
google cloud has committed to be 100
carbon free by 2030 every hour of every
day
now we also realize there's still a lot
to learn when it comes to building
sustainably and to help we just released
a master class called sustainable i.t
decoded with some of the world's top
experts so check it out for guidance on
how we can all build more
sustainably now while we're proud to run
the cleanest cloud in the industry we're
even more inspired by the work that our
customers are doing with google cloud to
solve climate change challenges that are
unique to their business and today we
bring you a preview of google earth
engine and its integration with google
cloud
with over 700 data sets and 50 petabytes
of data today earth engine gives
scientists and developers access to the
world's largest catalog of satellite
imagery and to tools for driving
sustainable impact
so let's look at this in a bit more
detail with an example of how google
earth engine and google cloud enable
customers to assess risks arising from
climate change but instead of me telling
you about it we've invited joel conkling
to show you
thanks saperna the world is constantly
changing and that creates opportunities
and risks
helping uncover critical insights about
the changing world is why we're
integrating earth engine into google
cloud now integration is now in private
preview
today i'll demo a workflow that combines
vertex ai
earth engine
bigquery and google maps platform
to show how google cloud makes it
incredibly easy for you to innovate and
deliver insights and do it quickly
so here's a scenario you work out an
insurance company and you need to
analyze your company's exposure to flood
risk you think new buildings may be a
strong contributor to that risk
and you want to test your hypothesis
to do that we first need to understand
where the built environment is expanding
in other words we just need to
categorize the surface of the entire
planet
that could be hard but vertex ai offers
the tooling to develop a best-in-class
ml model
and earth engine provides constantly
updated data
let's fast forward a bit we finished
training our model
and now earth engine is sending
satellite imagery to be categorized so
your understanding of the world can
update in near real time
here's the earth engine script showing
the results of that model this area in
red
is where the model estimates the
locations of buildings that's your
current built environment
to find the change over time
we need a few more lines of code
these lines of code give us a built
environment in 2016.
and here
we calculate the difference between 2016
and today
when there's a change it shows up in
purple
on the map
this is where there are new buildings
so next we're going to export sample and
export the data so we can do additional
analysis in bigquery
over in the bigquery console this script
clusters those data points
here
and then outputs polygons that show the
areas with the biggest changes in the
built environment
so at this point you have a few options
you could combine this data with flood
locations you identify around the world
also with earth engine
maybe you want to enhance your model
with weather data and physical terrain
data
that's available in earth engine too
you could also include data on your
company's insurance portfolio to gain
additional insight into critical risks
we'll wrap up this demo by visualizing
our results
in a new feature available on google
maps platform the open source dataviz
library deck gl
with a bigquery connector provided by
cardo
so we now have a clear picture of where
the built environment is changing and
where to focus next for our work on
flood risks
in summary
no wrangling data
no need to manage infrastructure
just actionable insights incredibly
quickly
we can't wait to see what you'll do with
earth engine's new integration with
google cloud
and with that i'll pass it back to
aperna
thank you joel
it's incredible to see how our customers
can use our sustainable technologies to
address climate change now
i'm really inspired by all the things
we've talked about today and thinking
about how you're going to lead your
companies into the future that's super
exciting
no pressure but it's really up to you
we've invested millions in the developer
community over the last five years and
will continue to invest in the coming
years
and orrs as proof of that i understand
you have some additional news to share
today
absolutely i'm really excited to
announce today our new developer
community program called google cloud
innovators
i want to welcome and introduce our
first group of leaders who are driving
meaningful impact
in the industry and their communities so
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is so exciting
yeah through this program we'll give
developers access to early technology
previews and google engineers
will recognize the expertise of our
community influencers by promoting their
contributions and we will work closely
with them to
solve the toughest problems so we're
excited to come together with this group
of innovators join us at
cloud.google.com
innovators so cool i've been waiting for
this all this time
community is extremely important for
companies to create that much needed
human connection with developers and we
hope that this gives you a window into
the motivation that you all give google
to build cloud products and services
that developers love
and we look forward to partnering with
you to become the greatest tech
companies in your industries
remember to join us next at the live
developer q a session and also tomorrow
at community day
enjoy the rest of the show
thanks everyone
[Music]
do
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining us today
for the developer live q a i'm aja
and a reminder that this q a is live if
you want to join the conversation reach
out on twitter with the hashtag google
cloud next
we've reached out asking for your
questions on social media and y'all have
been responding
we'll be answering your questions during
the next 20 minutes
and first of all let's welcome priyanka
who's here to answer your questions with
me today hi priyanka thanks aja that
keynote was absolutely amazing yeah so
let's get into the goodness that earth
and aparna shared a highlight for me was
really that upcoming documentary on
kubernetes so cool
i also enjoyed um the google cloud
innovator community announcement
securing software supply chain and
building sustainably uh what caught your
eye a lot of the stuff you just
mentioned um definitely our innovations
in sustainability the ability to see
your carbon footprint of your cloud
workloads is really really cool when i
heard about in yesterday's keynote i
immediately went and looked at all my
personal projects to see the carbon cost
of what i'd been doing and i love having
that kind of data to use in decision
making like
help me make the right decisions
but i'm mostly really excited about the
cloud innovators program i've really
missed interacting with our google cloud
dev community i want to hear and see all
the amazing things the community's been
up to
and the innovators program should let us
do that and we're working on some super
special innovators only events in 2022
that i can't wait to tell the community
about wow yeah that all sounds really
amazing i'm also excited about that
secure supply chain announcement salsa
and how the combination of cloud build
and binary authorization actually helps
kick-start your journey to secure your
software artifacts by fully automating
that build process
yeah that's just so interesting that's
so cool
so let's get to our first question we've
got questions coming in uh just for the
folks at home the backstage crew is
looking for your tweets as well so keep
them coming in during thing we'll be
bringing them in live
so our first question is from asher and
it is who would be good candidates for
the pursuit
participation in the private preview of
earth engine yeah so um anybody who is
like doing work on sustainable things
right so with the sustainability lens if
you're thinking about financial services
um the customer packaged goods and their
impact on the environment and how all of
that can be combined together so
yeah anything that that you're doing
with the sustainability lens obviously
it's in private preview so you have to
uh you have to qualify and stuff but but
if you have that angle of sustainability
you're probably a right fit for it
awesome thank you for that
ah second question came in from
priyanka's twitter and i saw this one
this morning as i was coming in to do
this q a
and this one is any examples do we have
any examples of end and spark based
pipelines for ml
they'd love to see them specifically
they're interested in learning how
serverless spark can be leveraged in big
data and ml ops framework on google
cloud
yeah so um uh thank you for this
question i think it came from parent i
saw my twitter this morning
um so uh really what it's all about is
the serverless spark ml framework is is
about you not having to create your
back-end infrastructure
to run sparks so that's all taken care
of for you so you can just run your
workloads which is in this case like
you're you're trying to run a machine
learning spark job you can just get
started by not worrying about the
infrastructure so that's one part the
other piece of it is the ml the vortex
workbench
which is the
jupiter notebook but but hosted uh but
it also gives you the opportunity to
connect with data proc or the spark ml
jobs that you might have built um and
and all run all of that so as a data
scientist i can just use my workbench
and that becomes my home to kind of get
the data massage it connect with data
procs spark ml jobs and then and then
get all those uh predictions right in
that one spot
awesome thanks brian that was a really
comprehensive answer
ah so now we have a question from
christopher and it's what are the
benefits of the innovators program you
mind if i take this one yeah please
so the big benefit of the innovators
program is going to be access to
innovators only events like we're going
to be doing some amas we're planning
right now road map meetings potentially
and there's also an innovator's virtual
background that you can download and use
in your google meet meetings
uh oh another question came in from
twitter
awesome
so let me read this one my pov massive
focus on the security massive focus on
the security focus in the developer
cloud isn't this a topic that matters
more for the managers of developers than
for developers and i'll take this one
too if that's cool with you yeah so i'm
a manager and yeah that's a really good
question security is vital to all
aspects of software development and
security needs to be everyone's job yeah
managers need to care a lot about it but
we need to make the tools so that
developers can do the right thing
automatically and that everyone is
participating in making our cloud more
secure
and we talked about some of those things
we talked about
our tooling that can help you make sure
that you put your secrets in secure
locations as opposed to putting them in
code we talked about the salsa we've
talked about lots of other parts and all
of this is part of secure software
supply chain but security does need to
be everyone's job
managers can help by teaching their
developers and enforcing it but everyone
needs to take the steps to make things
more secure
so yes good point but everyone's
involved
okay this is a great one from priyanka's
linkedin
is it possible to connect to the public
ip of a cloud sql instance from a
private cloud run service who have been
asked this one before when visiting
customers yeah also is this a cr is this
cross project setup
cloud run service and cloud sql instance
are on separate gcp projects so can you
do a cross project setup with your
database and you're running a service
somewhere else priyanka you you actually
can so you have in this scenario you
have a cloud sql instance in one project
and you have um your you have your
compute or whatever is calling that
cloud sql instance in another project
and you could totally make them work by
using um what is called as private
private service access what it does is
it connects the two together even with a
private ip so you don't even have to
expose a public ip for your for your
cloud sql instance which is again comes
back to the security point you were
making earlier everybody has to think
about security so you're not exposing
with public ip you're just using the
private ip of your cloud sql instance
and connecting it to the virtual machine
or uh wherever you're running your
compute to call your servers from so
it's possible private service access is
the service you're looking for to kind
of connect the two together it's a vpc
offering awesome thank you so much
bianca
cool a question from andy oh this is one
of my favorites so there's a lot of ways
to run an application on google cloud
it's a huge platform
how do i know what to what i should
choose where do i run my stuff should i
run it on gke compute engine cloud run
so many good choices
yeah this is this is a question we get a
lot right and it's um it really just
depends on your situation and the
situations can be a lot the type of team
the size of team um and the number of
number of developers you have and and
the and the languages that you might be
using so um there are lots of different
scenarios in which you can decide so
i'll give an example of a few so for
example compute engine like if you're
migrating and you just want to get from
on-premise infrastructure into cloud and
you just want the speed you just want to
get there um i would choose compute
engine to just migrate as is and then
modernize later if needed sometimes you
don't need to modernize if you have
licensing requirements and stuff like
that um so that's compute engine the um
if you want to work with containers need
a little bit more abstraction less
abstraction
you can work with containers with gke
and that gives you a lot more control
over the number of nodes you have and
and the processing that you're using um
but if you might be just wanting to run
containers but don't want to manage the
underlying infrastructure like nodes and
and stuff like that in the regions just
use cloud run because it's serverless
but it allows you to
use your container
container images and just deploy them
cloud functions is kind of like
everywhere so you're trying to do we
handle one function
or a piece of
a piece or a feature of code that you
just just deploy in a function um as a
as a function as a code sort of service
uh but it kind of applies everywhere so
i wouldn't say uh so cloud function is
not like a or a it's more of a and like
it works with with any of those it's
just more of an extension and
enhancement of your services with
serverless so i hope that that helped
clarify a little bit of that but there's
a lot that goes in that decision yeah i
know and i really liked how you called
out that cloud functions is not an or
it's an and it's cloud functions is just
fantastic at tying pieces together it's
one of the things i love about it
and i'm just going to point out for
folks that we have sessions on
all of these in the breakouts so if you
want to go learn more about these go
look in our breakouts and you can find
out more about the different offerings
that google cloud has
so now we have a question from esther
what language is the cloud run and cloud
function support oh let's see if i can
do this from memory i've been practicing
so gcf these are the standard languages
you see on google cloud we've got
node.js python go java java.net
ruby and php i got them all awesome
cloudrun supports any language or any
library or any binaries that you can put
in a container but if you want to use
the source code deploys feature that
abby showed earlier
that is supported on
node python go java and net and specific
versions of those languages are
supported so please do go to the website
and make sure the version that you need
is the one that we support
great memory by the way oh yeah i've
been getting really good at naming all
those languages
so from selena
oh yes great question when should i use
gke autopilot versus cloud run
um i'll let you take that let me take
this one okay
so
this
pretty much boils down to do you want
kubernetes or not
if you want kubernetes if you want the
enhanced flexibility that kubernetes has
you want to have all those knobs and
dials that you can turn to really fine
tune everything for your networking
needs or your particular load profile
use gke autopilot
if you want to can if you have a
container and you want to run it on gcp
and that's your goal cloud runs great
cloud runs fantastic at that
and as we pointed out you don't even
need a container if you use cloud cloud
run source deploys for those languages i
just mentioned
more questions
oh this one's for you priyanka this is
from caleb
what file formats are supported with the
doc ai stuff that any talked about oh
yeah so um you can do images and pdfs
it's really about the unstructured um
image data so pdfs and images awesome
okay
let's see what else we got
oh this one's from mark another one for
you priyanka oh it's another security
question
so can you tell us more about binary
authorization we covered it very briefly
in the keynote but it's something i've
been hearing a lot about and i'd love to
know a little more about it yes again it
kind of boils down to the whole like
security narrative that that you
mentioned that everybody's kind of
responsible for
um for the security of um the entire
platform so in this case
with binary authors really deploy time
security so you're deploying
in making sure that your images or
container images if you're using
gke or cloud run
works with binary auth so when you're at
your deployment stage uh you have uh you
you can provide signature authorizations
on your images um so if and the and the
um and the verification and the
authorities for those so if they are if
they are authorized only binary author
will apply the authorizations and once
the image is authorized only then you
can deploy it
awesome so i just got the signal that
we're running out of time so this is
going to unfortunately be the last
question
and this question comes from wesley
can i use the build integrity features
with my on-prem software
okay yeah so um you kind of can so um
with cloud build um it's really any
container image which is built on
cloud build you can use both on you can
use it in both on-prem or on google
cloud
you just have to use the binary at
binary auth test attestation cloud build
and
it's on it it's on the github page so
you can check that out but if you're
building it with in cloud build um you
can deploy it on prem or
in google cloud
thanks priyanka well that was a lot of
fun it was great to hear all the
questions from the audience you all had
some great ones and i want to say just a
huge thank you to priyanka for joining
us and answering so many of those
questions be sure to join us back over
on g dot co cloud next as the open
infrastructure spotlight will be kicking
off shortly and they have some amazing
things that they're going to show off
thanks for joining us everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i hope you enjoyed the dev
keynote i'm jeff reed vp of product for
application modernization platform at
google cloud thank you so much for being
with us here today
in most of my conversations with
customers i found they're accelerating
their technology adoption through the
use of cloud-based services to build and
deliver new capabilities like curbside
pickup and retail remote diagnostics and
manufacturing and completely new
experiences to better support their end
customers
today i'm going to share some exciting
announcements that will further empower
you to digitally transform your
organization
we recognize that each company has
unique cloud needs so we google cloud
are focused on three areas to support
you in whatever stage you are in your
cloud evolution first we set out to make
your migration or modernization path
easy with google cloud you can easily
evolve your existing applications or
build new cloud native apps
second
our open platform extends google cloud
services and engineering practices to
hybrid and multi-cloud environments for
consistent service delivery and third
our planet scale distributed
infrastructure is transformative and
delivers the highest level performance
and availability in a secure sustainable
way
one of our primary goals is to make it
easy for you to deploy and scale and
manage kubernetes anywhere
in the years since google invented
kubernetes containers have completely
revolutionized i.t operations given our
history it is not surprising that google
kubernetes engine gke is the leading
solution in the market and even gartner
agrees
in the recent gartner solution scorecard
gke scored 92 out of 100 making it the
absolute strongest strategic option
among public cloud kubernetes services
until now kubernetes has involved a fair
amount of manual configuration you have
to work you have to manage your own
clusters no gmo files it's a lot
with our introduction of gke autopilot a
new mode of operation in gke we're
making it much easier for you to use
kubernetes google provisions and manages
the entire cluster's underlying
infrastructure including the control
plane node pools worker nodes letting
you and your developers focus on your
software while gk autopilot manages all
aspects of the infrastructure in the
midst of the pandemic we saw a large
number of our customers adopting
serverless technologies and that's no
surprise since serverless technology
enables companies to rapidly develop and
deploy any application in a fully
automated environment with services like
cloud functions event arc and workflows
you can easily set up event driven
serverless workflows that connect into
google cloud third-party sas services or
your own applications
serverless is also about running complex
workloads at scale while still
preserving a delightful developer
experience
in fact serverless with cloud run is
about delivering a true developer
platform with the flexibility to run any
language
any library any binary you can bring
traditional workloads such as java
spring boot asp.net and more to
serverless compute now
whether it's gke autopilot cloud run or
cloud functions our goal is to make it
easy for you to build and scale apps how
you want and where you want
our second focus area is delivering an
open infrastructure cloud it relies on
open source based technology like
kubernetes istio and k native delivering
the portability you expect it also
offers you the choice and flexibility to
build and manage your apps across
multiple clouds
to realize these benefits enthos
operates as a cloud-backed control plane
that provides consistent development and
management at scale across both edge
on-premise and multi-cloud environments
it then enables you to build and manage
global fleets and establish operational
consistency at scale
let's hear from my colleague ray wang
who interviewed jahid kandaker and saraj
rao the cio and global head of advanced
analytics at western digital on their
multi-cloud journey
welcome and thank you for sharing our
insights with our audience
we have been working together since 2019
on western digital's cloud
transformation
what initially prompted you to focus on
modernizing applications and
standardizing software delivery across
your organization
thank you ray we are happy to be here
as a result of various merger and
accusations
wdc became an integration of three
corporations
hcst wdc and sandisk
to support very diverse infrastructure
and i.t environments across the three
entities
switching to a cloud strategy became an
imperative for driving to a
standardization now jahid mentioned
about the cloud strategy in 2018 we saw
tremendous growth in iot applications
from our global factories that required
low latency and high-speed on-premise
solutions
however now we were faced with this
daunting task of keeping our on-premise
and the cloud solutions synced up this
led to exploring solutions that provide
a uniform management plane across our
hybrid environment
after trying multiple solutions for over
two years we chose
anthus anthos gives us vendor agnostic
solution that works across gcp and
on-premise environments while keeping
the doors open for a multi-cloud future
that is great to hear go and those
so what does hybrid a multicast strategy
mean to western digital
sure ray western digital is making a
pivotal strategy shift to anthos for our
big data platform
we are migrating more than 25 business
critical applications seamlessly to this
hybrid environment with anthos
this move has several advantages
a richer user experience greater
security and enhanced flexibility to
manage factory applications
some of these critical applications
include image analysis on millions of
images a week for factory disposition
machine learning workloads for real-time
factory decisions and many many others
thank you that's a great strategy and
some amazing use cases
now looking forward what are upcoming
digital transformation goals in the next
three to five years for western digital
ray the future at western digital is
very exciting
we want to deliver
excellence everywhere
ultimately we see cloud technology
as an enabler of our key business
priorities
reduce time to deliver services
rationalize our application footprints
and meet customer demand for iot and age
applications
thank you jahid and suraj i look forward
to my amazing work from this great
partnership
thanks shaheed siraj and ray
since we announced anthos back in 2019
we are thrilled with the reception it
has received in the market in fact as of
q2 2021 anthos compute under management
grew more than 500 percent
year-over-year
and today we're extending anthos to
support even more workloads in more
environments and in more locations
we're announcing anthos for vms to
support development teams that want to
standardize in kubernetes but have
existing workloads running on virtual
machines that cannot be easily
containerized once you shift or attach
vms directly to the anthos environment
you can leverage declarative
configuration and policy management with
anthoconfig management and end in
application visibility and security with
antho service mesh
we're also introducing one of my
favorites anthos multi-cloud api which
enables you to provision and manage gke
clusters running on aws and azure
infrastructure through a centralized
google back control plane generally
available today
the anthos multi-cloud api ensures your
team has a consistent experience to
create
manage and update gke clusters
regardless of which major public cloud
you're using
thank you for joining us on the path to
revolutionizing cloud computing now i'm
going to hand it over to saatchi gupta
vp gm for infrastructure and long time
friend to talk about how we're extending
these innovations to your dedicated
environments
great thank you my friend it's great to
be here in person and it's great to see
you all
our goal in google cloud is to meet you
where you are in your digital
transformation
we understand some of your workloads
cannot move to the public cloud entirely
due to various factors such as high
amounts of local data processing low
latency requirements or strict data
security and privacy requirements but as
you heard yesterday from thomas we're
working to help you solve some of these
constraints
with the announcement of google
distributed cloud we're extending our
infrastructure to the edge and to your
own data centers this announcement
allows you to further digitize your
business applications by ensuring they
have the speed intelligence and
processing power in managed
heterogeneous environments and we're
approaching this from a differentiated
standpoint relative to other cloud
providers
first we bring google's ai and analytics
solutions closer to where the data is
being generated and consumed to harness
real-time insights second google
distributed cloud is enabled by anthos
it helps you to build and run
applications on gke clusters and virtual
machines anywhere with the cloud-backed
control plane for consistent management
at scale
and third our planet scale
infrastructure delivers the highest
level of performance and availability on
the most secure and sustainable platform
google distributed cloud is a fully
managed integrated hardware and software
solution
meaning you don't have to worry about
the underlying infrastructure and can
focus on your applications and business
initiatives
we aim to simplify operations leveraging
google's expertise and track record in
areas like scale deployment fleet
management and site reliability
engineering
this allows you to focus on your
business priorities and leave the
complexities to us
google distributed cloud is designed for
running sensitive workloads that meet
sovereignty requirements and offers
private 5g lte solutions for enterprise
customers
there are four deployment scenarios
depending on the customer's need
the google network edge
the operator edge the customer edge
and customer data centers
the first use case i'll talk through is
that google's network edge which is
designed for single and multi-tenant use
cases
leveraging over 140 google network edge
locations worldwide
next is the operator edge this is owned
by communication service providers for
both single and multi-tenant cloud use
cases
as i mentioned before you're better
you'll benefit from 5g lte services
provided by our operator partners
it can accommodate emerging services and
applications with stringent latency and
reliability requirements
for example online games and game
streaming depend on low latency to
preserve the end user experience
then we have the enterprise customer
edge these are customer owned edge
locations such as retail stores factory
floors or branch offices
which require localized compute and
processing directly in these edge
locations
next the customer data centers are
customer owned
facilities or cola facilities and are
set up for single and multi-tenant
hybrid scenarios it's also ideal for
life cycle management of virtual network
functions
for communication service providers that
reside on premises such as cloud native
build out of private 5g networks
google distributed cloud also includes a
hosted mode to run sensitive workloads
hosted mode helps you meet sovereignty
needs by addressing data residency with
strict security and privacy requirements
all while providing you with a way to
modernize on-premise deployments
customers can manage this directly or
host through a designated and trusted
partner
the good news is that hosted mode does
not require connectivity to google cloud
at any time to manage infrastructure and
uses a local control plane for
operations
upgrades and patches are offered by
google and verified by the trusted
partner
to learn more about how customers are
leveraging google's distributed cloud
i'd like to welcome rasheesh patel chief
product and platform officer atnp vasish
welcome to next
thanks sachin it's so good to be here
with you today rasish why don't we dig
right in and have you tell us about how
you are looking to leverage google's
distributed cloud for your edge and
computing needs
you bet i'd start with saying a t and
google have similar goals when it comes
to edge compute
we both want our business customers to
build and run modern applications close
to their end users by moving compute
workloads closer to the user we can
reduce latency to levels that will allow
for a whole new range of mobile
experiences that weren't possible before
sometimes this compute will be on the
network edge sometimes it will be at the
customer premise
but regardless of where the compute
workloads occur this is not something
att is going to do alone
that is tremendous it is really
fascinating how communications has been
able to influence business revolution
and it looks like you are poised to do
it all over again
so what kind of new business outcomes do
you think we can bring together with 5g
and edge you're absolutely right sachin
our goal is to create net new business
services and customer experiences
let me give you some industry examples
in retail services including
streamlining automated inventory
management predicting and managing cues
even enabling cashier-less checkout
options will come to life in healthcare
we see secure multi-git connectivity for
all devices within a hospital the advent
of remote patient diagnostics and care
and rapid data transfer between
field-based emergency medical services
like an ambulance and hospitals
and in the entertainment industry we're
enhancing in-venue experiences for
concerts and sporting events with
solutions ranging from immersive ar and
vr experiences
smart parking ticketless entry to
contactless food and souvenir payment
last question what are your goals for at
t and google partnership in the next
three to five years
well our work together brings market
transformative capabilities to
businesses across many industries
5g and fiber-based edge connectivity in
compute with google's powerful ecosystem
that includes maps voice recognition ai
android and many other capabilities
enables the development of these next
gen experiences in an accelerated time
to market
and we're looking forward to a lot of
expansion
we're bringing our network-based
solution with google cloud to over 15
major markets in the next several years
we have plans to roll out the services
in major metro markets including chicago
atlanta dallas miami san francisco and
many more so stay tuned thank you for
joining us rasheesh and we look forward
to continued success and delivering
joint value to our mutual customers
thank you again rasheesh thanks for
having me
everything you just heard about google
distributed cloud is made possible by
google's planet scale infrastructure to
ensure you are successful our
infrastructure delivers several key
differentiated benefits including a
global network construct
performant and customizable compute
services and reliable and secure storage
first at the core of this infrastructure
is the world's largest
and lowest latency network with 27
regions 82 zones and 146 points of
presence located in more than 200
countries
all interconnected with 16 sub-sea
cables
it enables companies like major league
baseball wayfarer and 1-800 flowers to
quickly migrate existing enterprise
workloads to google cloud and we're
continuing to invest in our global
network and global reach this year alone
we have already added four new cloud
regions warsaw delhi
melbourne and toronto
moreover with simpler networking
solutions such as network connectivity
center you can easily connect sd-wans
vpns and interconnects with a
centralized management model and monitor
the network with network intelligence
center
and with private service connect you can
connect at the service layer without
configuring the underlying network
second is our performant and
customizable compute platform
compute engine allows your applications
to achieve higher reliability security
and scale without any of the operational
toil we recently announced a new vm
family tau vms which is optimized for
scale out digital native workloads
tao vms offer 42 higher price
performance than alternatives from any
other leading cloud provider
as of today i'm also excited to announce
the preview release of new spot vms
with spot vms you can use excess compute
capacity at deeply discounted rates and
our new spot vms offer better savings
and more predictable pricing than
alternatives from any other leading
cloud
third our business continuity and
storage options
our strategy is about tailoring your
storage needs to your workload so we can
meet your price and performance needs to
advance our storage as the best option
for global enterprises we recently
introduced three important new services
the first is backup for gke which is an
easy cloud-native way for customers to
protect their configuration and data
running in their stateful containers
the second is file store enterprise a
cloud native managed nfs storage
solution that offers 99.99
availability sla and is ideal for
running enterprise applications such as
sap and gcp
and the third is additional robust
business continuity features for cloud
storage that extends the unique single
name space model we have with dual
region buckets
you now get more choice in where your
data is stored with custom dual region
buckets and the option of a new
market-leading 15-minute rpo sla
we're passionate about helping customers
continually evolve their approach to
modernization and bring more of their
applications and data to the cloud
google cloud is planet scale available
wherever you need it while also
providing cutting cutting-edge
innovations in performance and security
our goal is to make your journey to
cloud easy by offering transformative
capabilities to help you innovate faster
and save money through an open approach
that enables flexibility and choice
next i'm going to turn it over to the
demo team to bring the magic of google
cloud to life so stick around and after
the demo we'll be taking your questions
in a live q a see you then
[Music]
hey welcome everyone i'm richard hi i'm
vidya we're really glad you joined us
here today we're gonna have a lot of fun
talking tech and i wish you could be
here with us personally but we're live
at least and that means we can kind of
say anything like i could say google
should bring back google reader and
i'm still working here so that's awesome
if you have other hot takes you want to
share some feedback put it in the chat
we can see that stuff live right now so
keep it coming
if you can't see the live interactivity
please click on the blue
join live interactive experience button
on the next website and we'll see you on
the other side
for those of you just joining us from
the spotlight session you heard about
some of our new product announcements
including anthos for vms anthos
multicloud api and the google
distributed cloud yeah awesome in the
next 15 minutes we're actually going to
show you all of these in action which is
great so here's what we're going to do
together first we're going to migrate
something and demonstrate how to get
some new value from an old system by
moving vm based applications to a newer
containerized platform and we'll start
by showing you how to run a legacy app
in a server-less platform sir buckle up
video
next we'll create
we'll build a new experience for
customers through our ai powered
software and then we'll deploy with some
brand new deployment tools unique to
google cloud love it finally we're going
to be expanding our deployment targets
we're not just shipping the cloud
anymore but extending that awesome path
to production to other public clouds and
even closer to your customers at the
edge all right so let's switch some
things up shall we
i now work at symbol shops probably
because that google reader crack
so let's pretend that i am the director
of i.t at this company symbol shops and
like many of you our global business has
been shifted because of increasing
demands online
and at the same time we have some
problems so old software was never meant
for all the customer load we're putting
on it now it's holding us back we're
trying to offer mobile experiences
real-time stuff we have to do it as
quick as we can and look i can't rewrite
everything so how do we reduce some cost
and add some capabilities to that
existing software a little easier that
much too much effort so i want to start
with a smart migration approach you know
i want a repeatable efficient way to
move old systems to newer stuff maybe
even a serverless one but simple shop
needs help from our trusted partners at
google cloud help video you're my only
hope
i got you richard
so our fit assessment tool which you can
see here
is initiated from the google cloud
console
it helps us understand what can be
automatically migrated and which
workloads are going to be most
successful in their new home it's unique
to google cloud and saves you time
by pointing our migrate service at a set
of over 2000 virtual machines in our
on-prem vsphere environment we just
generated a fit assessment for the
workloads running in each of those vms
and remember
these vms could be running on-prem in
google cloud in aws or in azure so now
let's take a look at the result of the
assessment
see here we have a graphical view of our
most likely candidates for migration
this tool is particularly good at
detecting compatibility for older java
applications like java ee application
servers
now that we've assessed let's migrate
using our migrate service i'm taking a
java app running on websphere in an
on-prem vm and generating a container
image
that can run on any of our container
services all via automation
and you can see here that the classic
java app is now served up by our only
pay for what you use serverless
container product cloud run wow i love
that so this is great let me make sure
we knows what we just did there i mean i
don't have to manage all these partially
utilized virtual machines anymore
because you containerized it and i've
offloaded some of the operating system
management out to patch os's anymore
that's awesome and you've actually given
me access to brand new functionality and
saved me money by running in a modern
platform like cloud run so you just took
a classic java app and ran that on the
server list platform
it's pretty wild stuff if you like that
tell us in the chat that you have a need
for putting some of your older systems
in these newer platforms
all right so next up let's create some
new value and get that to google cloud
so simple shops has some problems we
want to solve we have a app that tracks
some of the store performance but it
runs in vms and it needs some serious
modernization to support all those sort
of new customer experiences and can keep
us competitive so this means upgrading
functionality and even changing how we
could deliver it to production it's a
curbside pickup super hot right now how
do i add functionality then to count how
many customers did curbside pick up each
day that seems really important vidya i
don't know can you help me with this one
yes of course i can so richard what does
your current app consist of well thank
you for asking our current app has a
mongodb database with multiple services
to track orders and pickups we actually
want to add new services and data to
capture and analyze that curbside pickup
info and to make that happen we could
look at historical footage from the past
day and count the pickups and do some
analysis later
this looks like a great opportunity to
do two things first
we're going to add google cloud ai to
process video footage and capture
metrics
second we'll containerize these
workloads and put them on a continuous
delivery pipeline so that it's easy to
keep making changes
i like that so if you do this then we
actually know how many customers are
doing curbside pickup maybe even how
long they were waiting and i think
you're going to fix them on my path to
prod and keep it make it easy to kind of
package and keep changing the software
over and over again i love that yes
absolutely check it out so google cloud
vision api can detect vehicles in this
footage to determine how well curbside
pickups have been going at each location
so now let's write some code and deploy
the updated app to google cloud uh this
is exciting and i'm hoping all our
audience is excited too i'm using visual
studio code here but i could easily use
intellij or any jetbrains ide
and using the no cost cloud code plugin
i can easily browse google cloud
services add them to my app and then
code and test this container-based app
you are the fastest coder i've ever seen
that was remarkable so that's pretty
simple too i like that so now that
everything's working locally how would
they then deploy this to the cloud let
me show you
first we need to package up this app
into a container
you probably want your developers
spending time writing code not docker
files and we can help with that
i'll show you how we like to package
containers and while i'm doing that
audience tell us how do you package your
containers
so here is our poll and we have four
options in our poll so i'm hoping you'd
actually pick it up
awesome so cloud build is a serverless
build tool that many customers use for
continuous integration
we also now support industry standard
cloud build packs to package up our app
into a container image automatically and
push it to artifact registry
artifact registry stores your container
images in regional repositories and here
you see that we automatically scan for
vulnerabilities
that's neat what else do we use artifact
registry for this is i haven't seen as
much about that can you tell me a little
bit about that yeah so while we use
artifact registry for storing docker
container images richard we can also use
it for storing all your language
specific artifacts in one place for
instance we just went ga with java
node.js and python packages using the
maven npm and pi pi repository formats
respectively
that's pretty cool so while we're
waiting for the poll results looking at
some of the chat i saw some questions
about how do we do day two management of
migrated workloads i think the my great
tooling gives you a container image that
now i could download to my desktop i can
run in different places i have different
ways to run that some other questions
about
again thinking about how do we
how do we migrate to uke and cloud run i
think these tools are pretty cool that
they can actually take an app and run it
in either one which is pretty great and
i think we're seeing the poll results
yeah it looks like the results are in
and
it's amazing that a lot of folks are
already automating today and they're
automating via dockable commands in ci
pipeline that's excellent
so now that we have a container in the
registry i think it's time to deploy it
so to deploy our app let's use the new
google cloud deploy service
a continuous delivery service for
deploying containerized workloads
while the service is containerized and
could run in gke or cloudron
the app is fairly coupled to our mongodb
infrastructure running in kubernetes and
is part of our multi-cloud strategy
so let's target one of our gke autopilot
clusters
gk autopilot is the fully managed
kubernetes service where google cloud
provisions
scales
upgrades and troubleshoots the cluster
for me
here we see a deployment pipeline that
helps us manage release candidates and
environments
cloud deploy helps us manage promotion
and rollout across these
environments and once the app is
deployed to gke autopilot you can start
using it from each retail store that you
have
you kick this all off with a push to get
and also you manually approve
a final promotion to production
in fact i'm going to have someone drop
the url in the chat window now so that
you can see it for yourself it all works
just like magic that's cool must be true
you put the link there that's great so
it's awesome so from development to
packaging deployment i mean i think
personally this is the best set of
integrated tools for services and
building containers that i've seen so i
think that's awesome
so we're also seeing some other folks in
the chat talking about some of these
components as well and what they're
seeing for migrating the apps and
hopefully clicking links and trying to
break the app we just deployed
all right so now that we've just taken
that existing app we added ai
functionality we dramatically changed
the knowledge that each of our stores
has about the customer experience that's
pretty cool
indeed isn't it richard what else do you
want to throw my way i think we got some
time so we've acquired a few other
retail chains who use different clouds i
mean nobody's perfect right so
at the same time this app needs to run
in more places so that each of those
stores can analyze curbside pickup
behavior regardless of what cloud
they're using so i guess video my
question for you is how do i run this
app everywhere
yeah that's a great question richard and
we do have a solution for consistency
across any environment
check out how we do it through anthos
with the new multi-cloud api
we can provision these clusters right
from the google cloud cli or console in
other clouds including aws and azure
where you already had some applications
installed
see here that i'm using a single g cloud
command to create a gke cluster on azure
here
we have deployed gke clusters to google
cloud
and microsoft azure i'm managing it all
from google cloud and i'm even able to
centrally deploy and view workloads to
any of these gke clusters
that's wild thanks vidya so
you're actually putting gke i think it's
the best kubernetes in the public cloud
anywhere i want it and that's that's
really powerful stuff i love that new
azure support and again each store
manager whatever cloud they're using can
actually see a report at the end of the
day to know how they performed on
curbside pickup that was the goal all
right but now you're making me think
that we could probably do more right we
could expand some of our thinking here
and maybe respond to the customer
demands in real time could we actually
evolve from that after the fact analysis
of parking lot footage to maybe improve
the experience in real time by that i'm
thinking of could i run this ai model
against live camera footage instead of
recorded stuff and maybe be able to do
something with it as it happens
of course as always new new challenges
emerge if we think of something like
this so off the top of my head we'd have
to somehow customize this ai model right
because now i have to identify the
number of cars in motion how many are
waiting is the curbside lot picking up
and i probably want to operationalize
that model and move it closer to the
store because i'm processing data in
real time so latency matters and then i
want to integrate all that insight i'm
getting with the existing in-store
systems for the managers to use so they
can move their employees around so
that's a lot of stuff i don't know can
you help me with that
we can
so i'm calling in my colleague gabriele
he has been working with one of your
on-prem locations richard in austin and
he can explain how we improve your
software for edge scenarios hi gabrielle
hi vidya and hello everyone uh glad to
join you richard uh by the way congrats
on your role in symbol
um what you're asking for can be solved
with our uni announced google
distributed cloud at the edge as such
you mentioned it brings the best of
google cloud to the edge it consists of
a fully managed cpu gpu optimized
platform with a common set of google and
third party applications
you build once and deploy anywhere as an
example here at some of your stores
so let's get going
we're going to add real-time
intelligence with ai models and process
the data locally to reduce video latency
let's get this running on the edge in
each store
so we start out by first using google
vertex ai
uh and so we train the engines and the
visual ai objects recognition and
classification models in the central
cloud
here we are monitoring the progress and
accuracy of the model
and as you can see the train models can
now be packaged into container images
right those container images can be
ready to be deployed anywhere including
at the edge
this case will be targeting five
different symbol stores
from the google console we can choose
the kubernetes clusters running at
specific edge locations across all the
single stores
once we pick those clusters we can
deploy the vision ai mode that we
created to each edge in the store
and manage those edge clusters just like
any other gke clusters
the symbol operations team has the same
familiar experience
only now
simba can also leverage the gpu
optimized google distributor cloud to
achieve better performance at lower
latency and as a fully managed service
distributed cloud comes with the same
integrated google cloud operation and
management capabilities that you're used
to
here uh you know symbol can monitor the
health and state of their store
deployments
manage capacity scale all of these using
the familiar google console and backed
by google sre practices
so as you can see uh in the video here a
real-time analysis of curbside service
level from the live footage
led to real-time insights for single
shops to build a better customer
experience at each store
specifically this new model at the edge
is recognizing cars in motion telling
you when the curbside pickup loads are
filling up
all executed in real time
so what do you think richard back to you
this is great you're amazing gabriella
that's i can't believe you built all
that all by yourself so this actually
gives all our store managers really new
insight into the real-time customer
experience letting those stores allocate
staff and people based on real-time
customer demand that's awesome so for
the audience out there i'm actually
interested what sort of apps do you
think about running at the edge is that
a real use case you're considering what
sort of things might run there all right
so i do love what you built for me i
don't want to be uh you know greedy but
i want a little more this app isn't an
island right you're doing some cool ai
containerized based stuff but there's a
lot of things already at that store
location right our notification services
other back office it's all in vms so
now that we have to integrate our new ai
customer service app these vm-based
systems am i signing up for completely
different management experiences across
containers and virtual machines or can
you do something for me
oh absolutely not your we're gonna
provide you the same experience uh with
the new antos for vms we can actually
help you bring those virtual machines
into the antus platform and manage them
the same way we manage containers
so see here
that i've moved a set of virtual
machines under antos management which
now gives me a straightforward way to
move and modernize existing apps at the
edge wow that's awesome there's nothing
you can't do gabriella that's great so
what's powerful here is that all the
google-powered fleet management in
google cloud other clouds at the edge is
all based on anthos with one open
control plane for wherever those
workloads run this simplifies our
operations a lot or that open foundation
makes hiring developers and operates a
heck of a lot easier all right so last
challenge for you symbol has this
growing european presence but some of
those regional stores operate with some
restrictions on data sovereignty i don't
want to sacrifice all the amazing
development and management capabilities
that you nvidia have shown me today so
is this a lost cause or do you have
something for me
uh yes we have something for you uh and
as we announced it yesterday with the
new google distributed cloud hosted
um we can use a single hardware and
software stack from google cloud but now
with local compute and a local control
plane it runs not only our container and
vm workloads but also the data and
application services we care about
you could run this
as an example with the original hoster
fully air-gapped and have local stores
connect directly to that
one open modern platform from whatever
you want to operate
i'm sold you've done it
so it's pretty cool so same anthos
control plane tech but also local
services in this fully air gap setting
that's great stuff thanks gabriela
appreciate you joining us here and video
did you like that i did actually and
gabriella that was amazing and i'm sure
our audience thinks so as well
over the last 15 minutes we've shown you
how google cloud offers a world-class
experience for building new software or
modernizing what you have
our solutions for container-based apps
are second to none and we're now making
it possible to extend those terrific
services to wherever you need us to be
all right thank you all for joining us
vidya gabriela as well this was terrific
stuff and thank you out there for the
chat and the engagement it was awesome
to see that so now stay tuned for the
live q a coming up next we're going to
talk about everything from the spotlight
all the way through to this demo get
your questions in there and we'll be
answering it live thanks so much bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right hi it's me again in case you
didn't tune in for that live demo that
just wrapped up i'm richard and i'm
sachin roger was nice to see you in your
new role symbol shops demo captain yeah
thanks for hiring me back i'm glad to be
back uh so our friends from the live
demo are going to be sticking around to
answer any of the questions you may have
so you may see their faces throughout
this show as well so let's just jump
right in with a little poll what gets
you fired up about tech using serverless
platforms running gke anywhere how about
continuously building software or heck
even just having breakfast for dinner
throw your uh throw your results in
there i'd love to see what you have to
say so while we wait for that a reminder
this q a is completely live you can
engage with us directly ask your
questions say hi in the chat yell at us
certainly sachin not me i'm doing my
best if you can't though go back to the
next event website click on that blue
join interactive experience button and
we'll wait for you over here all right
now time for some poll results let's see
what we have anything coming in so far
what do we think fires people up what
fires you up sachin look besides
breakfast for dinner it's all about
google distributed cloud i mean you know
the ability to have that consistent
management run anywhere meeting our
customers where they're at fully manage
solutions it's just absolutely
incredible and what gabriele showed up
there with vidya that was just fantastic
yeah that's a big deal well i'm looking
at the results so far uh you all are
just animals eating breakfast for dinner
so good job
yeah do whatever you want live your life
that's great
so let's get started with our first
question this one comes from jessica so
when would i use anthos on bare metal
infrastructure versus that google
distributed clouded edge how do i make a
decision between the two yeah that's a
great question thanks for the that
question so first of all let me just go
back to that symbol shops a retail
example
if you're a customer you have your own
hardware
it's customized for that environment
perhaps and you're just looking for
an a stack on top to run anthros bare
metal is a great option but if you're a
customer where you just want to consume
the whole stack hardware software
as a service and you want to leave all
that complexity to us then the google
distributed cloud product is a great
solution for that and so we want to be
very flexible about it you get to choose
based on what your needs are it's nice
to have the software-based option or the
software and hardware exactly exactly
because you know different customers
same customer we have two use cases as
well right but the same control plane
but the same control plane same
experience deploy you know write ones
build ones deploy anywhere yeah that's a
big deal yeah so this one's going to be
for you sachin as well we're just going
to pummel you with questions to start
with so this one comes from mike so i
don't know what val's asking those
questions let's switch questions up this
one's going to go the video i'll give
you a breather right now worry out on
that one so video this one's for you are
there other managed services that people
might want to adopt as they become more
cloud native what did they start picking
up as they start making this move to
cloud
yeah absolutely uh richard so as you
deploy more microservices
you can easily leverage our fully
managed serverless orchestration
products like workflows
or event arc so that you can connect as
well as coordinate
google cloud services such as cloud
functions
cloud run
http based api services including
third-party services so that you can all
tie them all up into serverless
workflows and this really helps you
address those type of use cases which
require business-critical
mission-critical workflows
so that you can actually have inbuilt
error handling retries
observability built in so that
everything actually executes reliably
and flawlessly
love it thank you very much video good
uh next one this one is for you sachin
buckle up here so robert from liberty
mutual is asking us about
kind of the the os support for for antho
so when i think about we know anthony
supports windows and linux which is
great so he's curious about what flavors
of linux will support aix so where are
we at on some of the operating systems
this the anti-support we have is
consistent with anthos that you have
from a software-only point of view yeah
so with google distribute cloud we just
carry it forward and what we're doing is
we're certifying that solution on top of
the
hardware that we've prescribed right and
i think there was a question that i was
seeing in chat which is about hey you
know what kind of hardware research
certified so we've gone in we've have
hardware from dell from hpe
uh we've got uh gpus from nvidia and so
it's a different for hardware for
different scenarios and then on top of
that whatever and those provides we can
bring to bear yeah and for anthony's on
bare metal just out of interest so you
can run rel centos ubuntu so we support
all of those as well so we do try to
give you a good set of choices there
awesome we're throwing more stuff at
sachin let's do it okay so are you
seeing any customer preference so far
for gke autopilot versus gke standard gk
standard's amazing it's got all the
knobs and dials autopilot's just turnkey
ready to go are you seeing any change in
preferences
first of all we've seen massive adoption
of gk autopilot so it's really opened
the door i think for many many customers
who wanted to get the benefit of
kubernetes and containers but wanted
it to be sort of automatically set up
for them
but you still have customers who
don't just want that kubernetes api they
actually want to have an existing
cluster or they have an environment
that's fine-tuned for their needs very
very large-scale deployments where gke
works great and so i think with the
combination of gk autopilot we can now
cater to
any of those needs yeah i think as we
looked at the data we've actually seen a
lot of autopilot customers are just new
google cloud customers as well as a
great first foray into kubernetes
exactly exactly they can get going so
quickly i mean again uh the demos that
were shown just now were fantastic right
just even i can use it yeah it's great
stuff exactly more stuff for you such
this one's coming from jude so how do i
choose which container oriented compute
service to use now we don't necessarily
have the 17 ways that other clouds offer
we have maybe fewer more focused
services but there's still choices i'm
not just one way to run containers so
how should someone make some decisions
there yeah so i think look we do try to
keep it simple but there are some
choices so if you have something that's
compute heavy
uh where
it's a lot of self-managed software that
you have self-managed services that
you're creating
it could be that you have your own
databases it could be a
middleware messaging
that's where we think gk is best
but if you're a consumer of a lot of the
managed services and you've got some
adjacent code that complements those
services then cloud run is fantastic and
so again not the 17 choices like you
mentioned but there are a few choices
based on how you're using that
containerized environment yeah that's a
crisp way of thinking about it good
stuff all right spencer's asking us
you know anthony's for vms is
interesting we announced that and it
seems wild we've been just talking
containers all this time now we're
talking vm so in the world is the use
case for that why would i think about
having anthos manage virtual machines a
great question once again and look again
we've been very clear about this we want
to meet customers where they're at and
while customers are looking to modernize
and want to be on gk on kubernetes
containerized they do have some software
components some applications that
require a vm environment and so the
ability to have that one consistent
management plan
and have the sort of lowered cost of
running vms or containers on top of
kubernetes that's a very powerful
combination so anthony's for vms is just
to make sure that while they're looking
to modernize whatever pieces of software
that they have
that requires that vm environment they
can bring it along consistently
as they do the transition yeah it seems
powerful against flatten maybe the
operational tool chain
just treat vm's containers the same way
that they're really going to simplify
hiring just management those sorts of
things exactly and you know if the vms
go away at some point great if they're
going to be there running next to the
containers that's great but that
consistency of management uh reduces the
operational cost yeah that's a great
call this one's gonna go to video so
alex is asking us about cloud run and
look this is something that we talk a
lot about we love cloud run cloud runs
terrific so what's new and interesting
there like what's been happening in the
cloud run world yeah uh thanks richard
um so here are some new features that
might be interesting
number one to further secure your
cloud-run environment
we just went ga with binary
authorization so that you can deploy
your trusted container images
number two
you can now run even more workloads for
instance workloads that may need
background processing and
we offered additional always on cpu
allocation controls which comes with new
pricing
there are no request fees memory and cpu
is priced about 25 lower
um the third feature that might be
interesting to call out is that while
cloud run free tier continues to exist
we also now recently introduced uh
committed use discounts so that you can
actually get up to 17
uh discount for over a year one year
commitment
that's great awesome thanks video yeah i
think some of the committed use stuff is
terrific same with the security features
i mean cloud run is one of the best
security oriented just container
runtimes out there in addition with gke
awesome another question this one's
coming in for you again sachin i'm glad
you're you're ready vladimir is asking
us what is the benefit of doing anthos
edge versus anthos on vmware and are
those even different i guess to start
with if we think about the question
could you do
on vmware at the edge you know how do
you think about then our
distributed cloud edge i guess kind of
help demystify this i think it's uh if i
think about the question it feels a
little bit similar to the previous
question uh which is what are you
actually trying to do if you're actually
trying to modernize then the anthous
environment where we provide that simple
management plane uh built on kubernetes
right where
you can run containerized applications
but you can also run
vms now that's a you're on a path to
modernization right that's that's what
you're looking for you're looking for
operational cost reduction
uh simplification but you want to be
into this sort of new world in the
containerized world uh that's where
their wins and so but there are going to
be other options on prem that you can
run and then similar to
you know perhaps uh other solutions that
may be out there where it's not just a
software layer you can package the
hardware sure and the software
completely together that's where google
distributed cloud that's built on anthos
comes together
so it really question are you looking to
modernize
is it just a legacy pure legacy
environment and that's how it's going to
remain if you're looking to modernize
and you need the flexibility of having
vms as well anthos and anthon for vms is
perfect yeah and if you have a vmware
footprint at the edge already then
obviously we can run right on top of
that and everything is amazing so again
i like the flexibility that will work
with what you have and look if you want
to run that vmware footprint inside
google cloud in our regions for that you
have google cloud vmware engine and and
we support that and so we're
very flexible based on what customers
are trying to achieve yeah awesome
another one for you such and this one's
uh i think it's interesting so i thought
anthos was already multi-cloud whether
we talked about with a multi-cloud api
weren't we already doing that or is
what's new with a multi-cloud api yes
anthon's look
has been multi-cloud for over a year now
right yeah and so the multi-cloud api is
really about
instead of having to bring up your your
clusters your gk clusters and the
control plane as well in every single
cloud you can now just run that control
plane in google cloud and then manage
those clusters that may be sitting in
you know aws rash or somewhere else
in a very very simple way through that
same control plane and so it's uh
further simplifying the
how you deploy those clusters and how
you manage them and
bringing you the the power of
uh gke uh and anthony's together yeah
now i love that demo of just showing a
single g cloud command because for
someone today you could deploy anthos on
aws but you'd first stand up that
management cluster and then spin up user
clusters it wasn't hard but can i just
simplify that can we take more
responsibility and it looks like we have
so i think it's really just a
simplification story
awesome this one's for me somehow so
awesome so how do i choose between gke
autopilot and cloud run look all the
pilot's amazing it feels like serverless
kubernetes right and that's why it's
kind of magic on how that behaves and
it's still all kubernetes under covers
there's no goofy extra extensiony stuff
this is just gke
cloud run is also kind of a serverless
environment so we look at the difference
between the two really it's about
do i to some extent do i want kubernetes
if i'm deploying marketplace offerings
i'm deploying a database i'm deploying
stateful workloads autopilot's going to
be amazing there right so that one's
pretty powerful and then at the same
time if i'm in cloud run and as you
mentioned earlier right i've got a lot
of managed services i'm using spanner
i'm using pub sub i'm doing aiml and i'm
putting some code in the gaps to connect
the dots to add some api endpoints cloud
runs amazing so i don't know i think
when i look at this and we look at
customers it's often a case where if i
want kubernetes gke is clearly a great
choice if i'm building compute intense
systems as you mentioned earlier gk is
amazing and autopilot's awesome and when
i'm just trying to run some containers
and i'm building things that kind of
connect dots between other managed
services cloud run is is best in class
yeah that's yeah it depends on your
starting point i guess yeah right yeah
but again not too many choices but just
enough
awesome this is another one for saatchin
as this one's coming from the ford motor
company folks is anthony's open source
is there any support available is this
just diy
live your life are we actually behind
the product helping people this
commercial offering help clear that up
yeah so first of all in terms of open
source it's built on kubernetes and so
uh
built on open source components is for
sure it enables our first party software
on top but also third-party
open source software that can run in
that containerized or vm environment
as far as support it's it's been
we now have more and more partners more
and more customers trained on anthos
anthos is the foundation
of google distributed cloud as well and
so we continue to invest heavily to
ensure that the training the enablement
the skills the capabilities get built up
in our customers in our partners to
continue and support those deployments
yeah i don't know if you want to add to
that on some of these efforts no it's a
great answer i mean we see so many
people take all this amazing open source
and build platforms which can be
powerful and anthos is actually 30
something odd open source projects that
come into one curated integrated tested
packaged commercial product as you say
and the multi-cloud support isn't best
effort we test this and certify it on
azure on amazon on prem on bare metal so
i think that's pretty powerful stuff
that
you know i know some people can still
get a little bit like what in the world
is anthos and i think it's important for
us to remind people that you know anthos
is really a way to build and manage
distributed fleets of infrastructure and
so what a powerful way to do that in a
supported fashion from the folks who
created multi-cloud with hardware
software together i mean yeah how do i
manage a bunch of gke clusters all over
the place exactly that's a really
powerful hopeful simple way to
understand this sort of thing yeah have
you continued to see that uptick as well
in anthos i know we're starting to see
some of the growth there
you're happy with where things are going
yes absolutely yeah we continue to see
great customer traction and now with
more as a service solutions with anthos
anthos for vms answers for bare metal
yeah continue to meet customers where
they're at putting in distributed cloud
is a powerful story for customers
because again i can make one
investment in my skills and now i can
take advantage of this in a lot of
places yes
awesome so next we want to go to a video
with this give for sachin a breather
and so uh fabian's asking
what the with everything and you know
containers are all over the place should
i just opt for cloud run instead of app
engine what's the future of app engine
in this context i like these edgy
questions video what do you got for me
yeah so um you know app engine is
obviously a very successful product for
us at google and serverless however we
see containers as a very very strong
position for the future of development
as you can see with all the demos that
we had and with um with technology such
as cloud run as well as gk autopilot
that has come into play it has got the
benefits of portability and better
integrations with the rest of gcp as
well as the cloud so that's the way we
look at it
that seems like a good answer i mean you
know google cloud's got a lot of these
stable services a lot of customers on
app engine but it's nice to have
alternates as people are looking for
other integrations things like that
cloud run is uh continuing to be a big
investment that's awesome softune this
one's for you
security questions i mean i i i was uh
personally impressed with a lot of and
enjoyed a lot of the keynotes from
yesterday as we looked at all the
investments we're making in security
here like if you're if you're trying to
make a choice on security i think google
cloud's your best choice and not just
because i work here
but how secure are some of these
clusters out of the box what we're
thinking about i'm assuming this refers
to amphos
you know when we stick either an anthoc
cluster
or gke cluster off-prem or even just a
gke cluster sitting in google cloud how
do you think about the security story
and how secure is this by default
by default what we're trying to do is
turn on all the best practices that that
we recommend
so that the communication channel that
you described is secure
if customers want to manage that with
their own keys they can but we want to
make sure that all the best practices so
that if it's uh
the days in transit the data's in rest
that by default we can keep that on for
customers um but i mean you should add
some more antho specific maybe uh
security capabilities that we turn on
yeah as you say there's a lot of
important things around os hardening how
we distribute bits they're coming from
us you can trust that as well that we're
putting them through the paces but then
with autopilot arguably one of the best
parts of autopilot is we just enable all
the security stuff by default right
because i don't know what i'm doing as
an end user myself when i send up stuff
so if you're turning on the right sort
of encryption at rest settings you're
turning on the right role-based access
you're turning based on continual
updates for patching i think that's
pretty awesome so in blood these cases
we're defaulting to secure i think one
of the other questions we get is how do
you handle this then in the air gap
environment
right so now like how
how does the customer get software
updates how do they make those secure
yeah and so what we do is we take the
software we publish it to a repository
uh the customer is able to
download it outside their air gap
check it for any vulnerabilities you
know test it out on their own and then
move it into the air gap and then the
platform will automatically deploy it
and so there's some additional checks
that they're able to add when they have
those very strict sovereignty data
privacy needs and need to be able to
check any piece of software that's
coming down it's powerful stuff all
right last question for you i could ask
you questions all day but i'm being told
i have to ask you a last question so
john wants to know as well so i'm
assuming this refers to distributed
cloud what whose hardware is this and
who does it run on and do you manage the
hardware platform as well let's at least
refer to distributed cloud are we
managing the hardware is it coming from
google are we making the kits or is it
coming from partners lay that out for us
real quick yes so we are it's
prescriptive hardware that we provide
and we manage
right and so in terms of how it's
supported again that's through done
through us we can do this through
partners as well and so what happens is
in a for example in an air gap in the
hosted mode
you may need to have a trusted partner
customer you want a trusted partner
who's actually doing the operations in
terms of hey i'm adding
adding a rack or adding more hardware
components sure but the software that we
provide manages that hardware
infrastructure that's deployed on-prem
and and the beauty of it is the control
plane there is completely disconnected
from google cloud as well so you have
both those options you know the
edge mode where it's connected we can do
it centrally across many sites or hosted
where that control plane is local but we
still manage the hardware
super powerful stuff love that so thank
you sachin thanks to all of our guests
who we threw questions to on the demo
set so
it's been awesome hearing from you all
getting all that feedback be sure to hop
over to the cloud next site and stay
tuned for phil and uh sunil talking
about security thank you
[Music]
hi there thanks for all that
participation in our q a and i hope
you're enjoying the show
so
welcome to security spotlight my name is
sunil purdy and i'm the vp and gm for
google cloud security
over the last few months we've seen some
of the most damaging cyber attacks in
history
you know against uh public utilities
private sector companies
government agencies
causing many organizations to realize
that at a pivotal moment in their
security journey
of course this is not news to
you know most of you in our industry
but let me put a few things in context
with a sobering statistic
did you know that the cost of cyber
crime is now estimated between
two and ten trillion dollars a year for
the past two decades google has made
security the cornerstone of our strategy
this has resulted in google enabling
more users to be safe than anyone else
in the world
block blocking malware phishing attempts
spam cyber attacks globally and not just
for a few thousands of websites but for
billions of users and millions of
websites globally
so that being said we also realize that
this journey
you know will require enduring
commitment over the coming years
and that's why google has committed to
invest
10 billion dollars for the next five
years to help strengthen cyber security
for enterprises consumers and
governments
we want you to be able to use our google
cloud security magic to protect your
enterprise
we make that possible in two ways first
we provide the industry's most trusted
cloud
for accelerating your digital
transformation efforts
and secondly
we bring trust to you with security
products that meet you where you are
and bring our google security magic to
your on-prem private and multi-cloud
environments
and it's just not about having
best-in-class security capabilities
it's also about how they're actually
delivered in a consumerized fashion
but at google cloud we take a different
approach
we're driven by a vision of invisible
security
where
security technologies are engineered in
so you get opinionated full stack
coverage of security controls
security operations as a silo disappears
so niche security talent gets
democratized and last but quite
significantly
shade responsibility in a world of
public cloud evolves to shared fate
where we as your provider have true skin
in the game
and mutual security outcomes
so a great example of what i mean by
invisible security
is the all-new built-in
data protection
automatic dlp for bigquery
it's a game-changing capability that
discovers and classifies sensitive data
for all of our bq projects
across your entire org without you
needing to do a single thing
and if you take a full step back and
internalize what invisible security
could mean for you
as an enterprise a service provider a
partner
or whoever it is there are three areas
where google's insight and experience
can make a meaningful difference
one
protecting your employees and assets
two protecting your ip
three
protecting your users and your brand
let me spend a bit of time on each of
these
first one of the most overused buzzwords
in cyber security today is zero trust
why not
the core of a zero trust approach
is the idea that implicit trust in any
single component of a complex
interconnected system can create serious
security risks
what does that mean is that
trust needs to be established via
multiple mechanisms and be verified
continuously
so here at google we have applied a zero
trust approach to most aspects of our
operations we've implemented zero trust
access with our beyond corporate
framework
shared our use case with the entire
world and delivered beyond corp
enterprise a world-class solution that
includes integrated threat and data
protection we've had great reception
to beyond cop enterprise since the
launch earlier this year and today we're
delivering capabilities that expand the
surface area for zero trust access to
cover all of your apps
both modern as well as legacy
so as a point of note right after this
session
the team will be doing a live
end-to-end demo of beyond cup enterprise
to show how you can make access easier
and more secure the google way so don't
miss it
next
protecting your assets is easier if it's
intentionally done upstream shifting
security left
and so zero trust is goes beyond access
to protecting your workloads as well and
your ip and how google operates our
production environment is in this way
the way software is conceived
produced managed and interacts with
other software
we call our approach beyond prod
and we've already productized many
capabilities for you
so looking at beyond carb and beyond
prod
you realize that zero trust is much more
than tools
zero trust is how we envision designing
deploying and operating safe
environments so our daily lives
as an enterprise or consumer
can go from a world of being
on the edge
to being safe
and safer with google
but you can lose sight of the fact that
while zero trust approaches help you
know address the preventative side of
your program robust detection and
response capabilities are needed to
complete the equation and this is why we
invest
in chronicle and we continue to amplify
it as our
foundational security operations
solution
and we are excited to announce stronger
integration between chronicle
and security command center sec on gcp
with centralization of alerts
the addition of cloud asset inventory
management and user context to enrich
investigations next let's talk a little
bit about protecting your intellectual
property so for organizations pursuing
digital transformation
code is your ip
it's the heart of your business
the foundation of securing your code
is a secure software supply check from
the time developers start writing code
through your ci cd pipeline
all the way to deploying and operating
in production
so at google cloud we believe two things
are foundationally necessary
for doing this in an enduring fashion
one industry-wide frameworks and
standards
are a must
but they also need to be complemented by
full stack managed services that
implement these standards and make
adoption easy
so for the first
google co-founded open ssf across
industry forum for open source and
supply chain software security
with projects such as salsa
an end-to-end framework
for ensuring the integrity of software
artifacts and second we have the
all-star github app right in time for
the fall season
for continuous enforcement of best
practices for github projects
and then last but not least open source
scorecards which provide
a risk score
for open source projects
and these are just a few ways google is
contributing to industry-wide standards
and on google cloud with our invisible
security approach we provide these tools
in a fully managed environment from code
to build
deploy
run and operate that implement these
standards by default
and let's not forget you also get a
consistent way to define an enforced
policy for a zero trust software supply
chain that establishes provenance
and prevents modification or tampering
and we're building this zero trust
software supply chain with new additions
across the board
you can learn more about all of these
launches in our breakout sessions
so to add some more
you know context to this with new voices
in our conversation on these topics
i'd like to bring on marie from facebook
and steph who leads our cloud security
user experience team stafford murray
over to you
thanks sunil and welcome murray can you
tell us about your role at facebook and
what that work entails sure uh i'm a
manager supporting the cloud foundation
team within facebook cloud foundation is
chartered to help teams with a need to
use public clouds for their workloads so
that they can do so both quickly and
safely can you talk about how facebook
is leveraging zero trust secure supply
chains or other modern cyber security
solutions facebook focuses a lot of
engineering effort on secure supply
chains this extends to our use of the
cloud as well so our workloads that will
run externally have all of the same
requirements as the internal ones in
terms of security vulnerability
management security logging monitoring
tight access control to resources access
auditing data deletion requirements
penetration testing mandatory reviews of
anything with privacy implications and
so on one approach we're taking is that
our teams can't use any uis or directly
control the services they build in the
cloud they have to go through our tool
suite to do it
some of our
suite uses open source
common open source tools which means
there are vast online help resources
available to enable our teams to design
and build their services
then we provide our own extensions so
that these tools integrated with our
existing internal development workflows
logging systems dashboards etc
it also allows us to impose our own
guard rails and best practices its
infrastructure is code in the truest
sense
naturally we already have an internal ci
cd system that's used to update our
internal services on a regular basis
after appropriate code reviews and
automated testing so i'd love to wrap up
by hearing about your experiences what
your team uses to keep facebook
fortified and continually strengthen its
security posture and two partnering one
of the capabilities that our tool chain
allows is to inspect what the deployment
is going to do before it happens which
gives us an opportunity to impose best
practices or error checking and stop
problems from going live
some of these rules shield us from
accidental security exposures some look
for weak deployment practices such as a
lack of redundancy and still others look
for avoidably expensive practices these
rules applied here are based on both our
own experiences and policies and those
recommended by our expert partner team
supporting us this allows us to be agile
and respond to incidents when they come
to our attention
thanks bharara and steph
interesting to see how these ideas are
implemented and i'm excited to see where
we'll continue to go together
okay so let's move beyond our
infrastructure for a moment and think
about the big picture
the software that runs your business
delivers value to your customers and
your users
the security you're building is designed
to protect the users and build trust
between them and you
security incidents erode that trust and
eventually damage your brand
so now google keeps more users safe
online than anyone else on the world
so let's see how we are advancing our
efforts
and delivering all these capabilities to
enterprises wherever you are eradicating
phishing
as well as completely stopping fraud
period and in this area
safe browsing is the gold standard
our program to protect users from
dangerous sites or files is
unprecedented in its reach and
capability
its capabilities are invisibly baked
into browsers on four billion plus
devices
last year alone we advanced the state of
the art with enhanced data browsing
an optional but more advanced level of
safe security for safe browsing the web
and by sharing real-time browsing data
in a privacy preserving way
we were able to
deliver a 35
additional reduction in phishing attacks
and malware
that reach users
these kinds of numbers and this kind of
efficacy
has
not been possible without leaning in on
our heritage
and our core competencies in providing
security as a built-in capability to
consumers as well as enterprises
wherever they are
and since this introduction in april
2020
in addition to safe browsing
millions of users have taken advantage
of this extra protection in a very rapid
fashion
so our ultimate goal is to eliminate
phishing as a threat
period
bringing safe browsing capabilities into
your environment through gmail
beyond cop enterprise and many other
products so in addition to targeting
users directly
attackers view websites as the first and
often easiest
place to commit fraud
and over 5 million sites today use
recaptcha our fraud and bot management
solution that stops attacks like
credential stuffing and account
takeovers
with recaptcha enterprise you can do
this frictionlessly
without user challenges to maintain an
optimal user experience
which is just another example of
invisible security
and over and above this we continue to
bring together the best of google's
capabilities to enhance fraud prevention
so a new integration between cloud armor
and recaptcha enterprise that detects
and stops back bot activity at the edge
is now in preview
so let's hear more from brian lozada the
cso at hbo max on how they're actually
using recaptcha enterprise to protect
their users and therefore their brand
thank you sunil
we chose recaptcha enterprise because we
wanted to offer our customers security
against malicious actors while
continuing to provide a frictionless
customer experience
with recaptcha enterprise we enable our
customers through our login and
registration process
without requiring them to engage in any
kind of a challenge it's a win for
everyone
our development and product
organizations can continue to focus on
creating customer-centric experiences
and our customers can easily use our
services the use of recaptcha has helped
us in our mission to secure the customer
experience allowing our customers to
feel comfortable while enjoying our
platform thank you
thank you brian so we want to provide as
much assistance as possible in your
digital transformation
or your security transformation
as thomas mentioned in this keynote we
are excited to launch our new google
cyber security action team to help
and to talk more about this i'd love to
kind of bring on phil venables or cloud
cso who's leading this effort to tell
you more phil
thanks neil
so the google cyber security action team
marshals experts from across google to
form what we believe will be the world's
premier security advisory team
it has a singular mission supporting the
security and digital transformation of
government critical infrastructure
enterprises small businesses consumers
and society overall
to deliver on this mission there are
many ways the gcat can help you today
with strategic advisory services for
your security strategy including
transformational workshops and content
like our cso guide to cloud security
transformation and our framework for
increasing operational resilience for
financial services organizations
with trust and compliance services
driven by specialists who continually
obtain the most important global
compliance certifications for our
products and map them to industry
control frameworks for you
we have full spectrum customer security
and solutions engineering that delivers
proven blueprints and architectures for
deploying our products and services
securely in accordance with your
regulatory regimes as well as
comprehensive solutions for areas like
autonomic security operations cyber
resilience zero trust architectures and
many more we've got under development
and finally with threat intelligence and
incident response services including
threat briefings preparedness drills and
rapid response engagements so you can
stay on top of the evolving threat and
security landscape
another way we're working to help
strengthen and transform security is by
working with industry and the public
sector
google cloud joined as an initial
partner for the us department of
homeland security's joint cyber defense
collaborative and this initiative will
will strengthen our collective security
posture by preempting and reducing the
impact of cyber threats through
increasingly strong partnerships between
the public and private sectors and as
sunil mentioned at the white house cyber
security summit in august we announced
that google will invest 10 billion
dollars over the next five years to
further strengthen cyber security
the areas addressed included expanding
xero trust programs securing the
software supply chain enhancing open
source security as well as training a
hundred thousand americans in skills
including data privacy and security
through our google career certificate
program and this builds on the 100
million dollars we've already committed
to improving open source security
focused on efforts like linux kernel
development and work like metrics
tracking and the coordinated
vulnerability disclosure through the
open source security foundation so with
that sunil back to you to wrap up
thanks phil great stuff as you can see
our commitment to improving security for
customers and the whole ecosystem is
substantial and more importantly it's
enduring
in products
in resources
and monetary terms
we're making a meaningful difference
with our long range
vision and commitment of invisible
security
delivering continuously around zero
trust
safely securing your software supply
chain
and delivering user protection services
to protect your users and your brand
so to close i mentioned a few new
products and i didn't have time to cover
all the other amazing innovations that
are coming out of our teams
and we're making many more such
announcements here at next
so please see our security experts
fellow customers and partners in our
track sessions to go deep on the topics
and products that matter most to you
so don't forget the live demo of
beyondcup enterprise is coming up next
right here followed by a live q a where
we will be answering your top questions
thanks again stay secure and have a
great rest of next
[Music]
hi everyone i'm marco and i'm tanisha in
the security spotlight we heard about
the importance of a zero trust approach
to security and in our demo today we
will show you how to implement zero
trust access to be more secure and more
productive and a quick shout out to our
audience this is truly live dive into
the chat we want to hear from you tell
us what you do and where you're joining
from we can see you check it out marco
sure enough we can see everybody down
here and we're so excited to interact
and talk to you all today
if you're still hanging out on the next
event website click on the blue button
that says join the interactive
experience to activate these features
okay so let's get into it we're going to
cover three things
one how your entire workforce can
securely access legacy and modern
applications without exposing your
network to attacks and two how you can
get better protection against threats
and data loss
right from within your browser and three
how you can gain visibility into unsafe
activity even if users aren't on a
corporate network or device and we're
gonna do all of this with beyondcorp
enterprise beyondcorp enterprise or bce
as we call it is google cloud's zero
trust access solution with bce you can
use chrome to access apps and resources
in the background google's network
protects and proxies traffic enforcing
access policies these policies use
factors such as identity device info
location and third-party signals to
authorize access to apps and data that
you need to do your job
that's awesome marco so let's get to the
good stuff think about it how easy is it
for your developers to work remotely and
securely right now
we know it's a tough task we know that
making life easy for developers while
also protecting your code is critical
that's why our new beyondcorp enterprise
feature client connector is so important
it enables zero chest access to legacy
thick client applications yeah i think a
lot of people run into that today
so let's take a look at how developers
would use it we set up this laptop for
the symbol group
by the way they're a fictional company
symbol has been around since the 1970s
and they haven't modernized all their
applications sound familiar one of their
main developer applications is still
hosted in a private data center yeah i
see this quite a bit until recently
symbol developers didn't have a way to
access this application remotely without
a vpn the security team had constant
concerns that remote users could expose
the network or even worse their source
code to attacks or hackers but now using
beyond corporate enterprise client
connector they can access client server
apps without a vpn let me show you how
simple developers would connect via ssh
to their git repository and before i
show you let me just say
don't blink or you might miss it it's
that simple
so
let's go ahead and swing on over to our
developer machine
from here i can simply open up google
chrome
once google chrome has actually loaded
you can see i've authenticated to my kit
application repository already up in the
right hand corner i simply click on my
endpoint verification extension
and from here i click on start
connection my endpoint is being posted
in the background and a secure
connection is being made to gitlab
from there i can simply then once it's
turned green of course minimize my
browser
and then on the left hand side i'm going
to go ahead and open up my terminal
application this is my thick client
application
i'm going to then go ahead and run a git
clone
and that's actually going to pull down
the code from git to my local machine
and there's my application pulled down
locally onto my endpoint
i know that probably seemed pretty
straightforward but what you might not
have noticed was first
there were no clients it's all in the
browser you probably already had open
second in the background continuously
validating the identity and the device
and a bunch of other factors
is our identity uh where proxy and third
our tcp proxy seamlessly and
securely forwards all the traffic the
fact that developers around the world
can do this remotely
simply and securely
without all the hassle of a vpn is
pretty awesome
and with beyondcarb enterprise workers
are only allowed access to applications
they're permitted to use so we prevent
unwanted lateral movement across the
network
so audience we want to know would you
use this method for remote access in
your organization
awesome
now let's see how your workforce can
securely access modern web applications
even from non-corporate devices
let's look at how symbol does it for
their extended workforce their call
center contractors
meet rhonda she's one of thousands of
remote contractors who help with symbols
24 7 support during the holiday shopping
season
so security community can you share in
our chat
in the past year have you onboarded new
temporary workers did you send them a
laptop or make them install software so
they could be more secure
looks like that would be a yes
contractors also tend to be more
vulnerable to attacks last year 44 of
organizations experienced a breach and
74 of those breaches were the result of
giving too much privileged access to
third parties so for symbol keeping
those users off the corporate network
decreases the risk of being exposed to
attacks like ransomware
and here's where using beyondcorp
enterprise comes through again for
symbol
contractors and other employees are able
to byod on board quickly and use a
device that they feel comfortable with
while bce layers of protection keep them
secure
that way rhonda can have secure access
from our own device with clear
separation between work and personal
activity let me show you exactly what
she sees as she begins her day
she first navigates to her google chrome
browser
then she navigates to her symbol call
center application
we'll enter in our credentials
we'll then do two f two factor
authentication with our time security
key
now that we've passed
two-factor authentication
we are in our symbol call center
application
you saw rhonda log into chrome with her
symbol credentials this is what we call
a beyond core protected profile it
extends threat and data protection as
soon as she logs in as you can see our
agentless approach means no additional
software she gets right to work on her
own device rather than picking up a
laptop from it and waiting hours while
everything gets configured therefore
saving time and money
awesome demo tanisha and the thing about
zero trust access is that we don't
automatically trust rhonda just because
she has login credentials authorization
is continuous
not just when she first logs in beyond
corp enterprise enforces symbols
contractor access policies based on her
identity and contextual information
about her device and location as well as
the fact that she's authenticated with
her titan key
so security community we want to know
what do you all use for multi-factor
authentication
sms codes security keys maybe an
authentication app or maybe something
else completely hopefully it's not
nothing
for me it's my security key every day
especially since i don't always have my
phone on me
yeah same here and they're so easy to
use and they provide the strongest
protection against phishing regardless
of what you use some form of
multi-factor authentication is critical
for basic security hygiene and we highly
recommend it especially for remote
access so let's take a look
i don't know if anybody has anything
looks like um
most people use let's say security keys
b awesome that's what we love to hear so
let's get back to ronda who just
authenticated to the app and explore how
we can integrate threat and data
protection
right from within our browser
great let's see our get to work and show
a bce protect symbol their customers and
rhonda with ease it's been a really busy
day she doesn't have enough time to
finish processing a batch of customer
refunds before her next call she wants
to save the customer credit card
information to a local file and do the
refunds when things slow down but saving
the sensitive information to another
location is against symbol security
policy let me show you her experience
let's navigate to our credit card file
and let's download this so ronda can do
the refunds at another time
as you can see she is blocked you can
see a message appear at the bottom that
prevents her from doing so
yeah exactly we can actually see where
the credit card pdf has sensitive
dangerous content inside of it and i'll
show you a policy that's been configured
for symbol
that will detect risky behaviors just
like these
so let's go ahead and look at our
administrative console here
admin.google.com
over on the left hand side
you can see the security menu
and if you scroll down underneath
security you can actually see data
protection
and we're going to go ahead and
authenticate obviously as administrator
securely so let's go ahead and type in
our password
and once i've authenticated i'll be able
to go ahead and look at my data
protection policies you'll notice here
it says manage rules so we're going to
go ahead and drill into manage rules and
we can actually see now the credit card
detection policy that run is hitting
right here i've also got detectors for
things like social security or even
detecting code that's being copied or
pasted or shared
by the developers so
as the admin you can decide if you want
to automatically block user actions as
symbol is done here
or if you want to trigger warning to the
user instead
and in addition to things like credit
card numbers you can also set specific
dlp policies to detect file type as
source code so that way you can protect
sensitive information and code by
monitoring controlling or even blocking
what people upload or download
exactly
we can use very granular policies for
this type of information in order to
protect against exfiltration so we just
showed you some of the types of data
protection policies you can set up
you can also customize access policies
and the changes take effect in real time
this is a really big deal because you
get continuous checking of whether a
user is in or out of policy giving you
up to the second security controls
in fact
let's make an update here in real time
for ronda so okay community we're going
to ask you which policy we should change
is it her location maybe her operating
system policy or whether or not she's on
a corporate owned device
please chime in here we'd really love to
understand and hear what what you guys
deem important while we wait for the
results to come in
i will say that i see these kinds of
things all the time with my customers
they want to be able to dynamically
change policies depending on their
circumstances
in particular some customers are really
interested in controlling for location
perhaps limiting access to only certain
countries
additionally if a company is going
through an org change or maybe a merger
being able to change access policies for
select groups of users or departments in
real time is crucial and beyond these
three choices in the poll there are many
other ways to customize your access
policies based on what your organization
needs
so let's go ahead and look back at the
polls
and looks like corporate on device
so awesome
i love it and thanks for everybody
contributing let's go ahead and do this
right now
so we're going to go ahead and jump on
over into our gcp cloud console and from
here we can see our identity where proxy
you can actually see our symbol get lab
for our developer
application we can also see our call
center application
and again these applications could be
anywhere for this demo they're in gcp
we're going to go ahead and select the
call center application and down at the
bottom we can see
rhonda over on the right hand side in
her application access policy let's go
ahead and edit that and we're going to
go ahead and remove the existing access
policy that's allowing access from
europe and the us
and we're going to go ahead and delete
that one and we're going to add a new
role
we're simply going to go ahead and
select cloud iap
iep web app user and then from there
we're going to go ahead and select the
access policy which everybody chose and
that was required corporate device right
okay just want to make sure i remembered
that correctly let's go ahead and save
that in place
click save
and when we save that policy it's
actually going to be propagated across
the world within a very short period of
time
all of the proxies across google's
global network are immediately updated
so the next time any user tries to
access a protected resource they're
evaluated against that new policy set we
mentioned continuous authorization
earlier and this is a key part of that
authorization is not a one-time
occurrence so even if you begin a new
session that doesn't mean you'll have
perpetual access
exactly and for companies like symbol
that employ hourly and temp workers the
ability to dynamically update access
conditions is important for instance
they could set these policies so workers
only access applications and resources
during their shift hours or working days
or only allow access from only allow
access from specific geographies they
also may want to require that devices
have the most up-to-date operating
systems and security patches so this is
an important condition to manage
especially for all the contractors using
their own devices
exactly so because rhonda doesn't meet
that condition which i just updated
she will no longer be able to access the
call center application
now
i think we've all faced this and it's
one of the most frustrating things about
remote access especially when you're
using the vpn you think you should have
access to something but for some reason
it's just not working
it's the worst
so let's see if our real-time change
worked so when ronda tries to open a new
task in the call center application
let's take a look at what she sees
let's navigate back to her home
and she's denied access as a result of
the change marco just did but once again
bce has rhonda covered she can report
this error using our new feature the
beyondcorp enterprise policy
troubleshooter which informs end users
that they're blocked and tells them how
to get help quickly so as you can see
here she would follow the prompt to
email the admin to get help
let's go ahead and email our admin
our admin is now notified of us being
blocked with beyond corp enterprise
policy troubleshooter admins can quickly
fix issues that are blocking users
keeping them productive
yep you bet let me show you what the
symbol admin would see on the other side
of this request and how they can unblock
users like ronda
so we're going to go ahead and switch
gears let's go over to gmail
another google application
and it looks like we got a notification
for credit card detection which is good
so
we know if rhonda is taking some
interesting actions within her endpoint
oh and it looks like we just got an
email from rhonda because she's actually
been blocked to an application there's
the link that she sent over so let's go
ahead and click on that and we'll
automatically be logged directly into
the google cloud platform
so from here i can actually see the
different policies and bindings that are
in place so let's go ahead and select
the call center application and over on
the right hand side here we can actually
see the the the granted conditions or
the denials themselves so let's go ahead
and look at the binding details so
interestingly here we can see that
rhonda failed to meet any of the listed
access levels and sure enough it's
requiring a corporate device which was
not granted
so i normally go back in a blocker by
updating that policy so our access level
is evaluated like any other contractor
but we're going to keep moving just the
interest of time sounds good that was so
easy by the way
yeah super easy now let's look how bc
can give us better visibility into
unsafe user activities whether they're
unsuccessful access attempts like we
just saw
or other anomalous activities across the
apps that bc protects let me pull up the
security dashboards in chrome and give
you all a look
so we're going to jump back over
into our google admin console here and
in the same security menu on the left
hand side we can actually click on
dashboards
wait for those to load out for a second
so
something to make note of here is that
with chrome data protection you're
actually going to get a whole slew of
different
information we can see chrome high-risk
users we can see individual dlp
incidents if we want to scroll down a
little bit we could actually see how
many users are forgetting
their their passwords if i can figure
out how to use a trackpad here
so we can see user login attempts we can
see for example messages that are
encrypted but we're interested in is
whether or not
those uh those credit card numbers are
making it through so let's go ahead and
drill a little bit into one of these
reports
so we can see every single file uploaded
file downloaded web content upload for
example and we can actually see every
single time that this took place for our
social security detection as well as
credit card detection and if we were to
actually drill in on credit card
detection here and i think this is
really cool so i'm going to show
everybody real quick here since we do
have like another minute and that is uh
all the sensitive data transfers that
are taking place blocked detected or
otherwise so even if your organization
isn't using all corporate owned devices
you can still monitor security events
and investigate those alerts that's
awesome marco audience so what do you
think let's let us know in the chat
we definitely know this is something of
interest
in the last 15 minutes you've seen how
entire workforce can access modern and
legacy applications securely how you can
improve threat and data protection and
how you can get better visibility into
risky activity even on unmanaged devices
yeah
our goal right at the end of the day
with beyondcorp enterprise is to make
your experience more productive and more
secure and our team looks forward to
supporting you on your zero trust
journey
thanks so much for joining us today and
participating we have a live q a coming
up next to answer all of your google
cloud security questions as well as any
questions you might have had from the
demo so please stick around
yeah please do and thank you all for
joining we'll see you all soon
bye
[Music]
awesome thanks so much tanisha and marco
that's an incredible demo it's always
fun to see our products in action and
i'm sure between the great spotlight
earlier the demo our audience has some
great questions lined up
so thank you for joining everyone today
my name is iman
and i'm sri i'm so thrilled to be here
answering your questions live from our
fabulous studio here in sunnyvale
awesome we're also joined by the team
that just took you through that live
demo just a few minutes ago so you may
see them pop up to help answer questions
throughout the show
okay
let's jump right in with a little poll
tell us what got you most excited today
is it our trusted cloud is it our zero
trust philosophy is it our 10 billion
dollar cyber security investment or is
it the cyber security action team
and by the way i'm waiting for these
poll results so while we wait for these
results just a reminder this q a is live
so you can engage with us directly so
steve brian dinesh
i'm watching all of you right here live
on the chat
so if you can't just go back to the next
event website and click on the blue join
the interactive experience button
and as we give you some time to submit
your poll i want to hear the scoop from
you sri so tell us what you're most
excited about i am really excited about
the zero trust model i feel like we're
kind of adopting it
and we're seeing a lot of people
move toward it so
yeah yeah i mean we've been doing this
for so long right you know we're taking
an approach that we've pioneered and
we're putting it out in the world and
we're watching a lot of customers sort
of adopting this uh this approach now
yes absolutely awesome awesome oh it
looks like it is it looks like it is
yeah yeah that's right that's right
looks like uh looks like a lot of people
are really excited about zero trust
that's that's amazing okay cool
what's what's the next runner up we've
got our 10 billion cyber security
investment
but zero trust is definitely leading by
by a a pretty big margin all right so
let's uh let's go ahead and get started
let's let's kick off our first question
yeah all right
all right cool so um i guess while we're
waiting for you know questions from the
audience to populate um the question i
have for you is
why is security dominating the headlines
you have to be under a rock to not like
you know notice all the stuff that's
happening around us all the ipos with
sentinel 1 and
forge rock and dark trace and
we're seeing presidents and prime
ministers
uh commit
a large amount a giant amount of dollars
including our new president
to security and so i think there are two
things here typically an industry uh
we'll see a lot of movement because
there is a technology shift that happens
and we're seeing that too with the
digital transformation you know the way
that we secure our environments has
changed and so there's a lot of movement
that's happening in this industry
because of that
added to that security has this other
thing where it's also driven by the
people who are attacking the you know
the attacks that are happening and we're
seeing a huge amount of attacks
happening today
and as a result like for example we've
had i mean this is really sad we've had
our first
death that happened because of a
ransomware this year
we've had
a pipeline company have to pay a ton of
money for ransomware we had we have had
manufacturing companies get disrupted in
their manufacturing a
distillery company um uh basically had a
disruption pretty recently and so we're
seeing a lot of this happen all around
us and that's kind of adding
more
you know focus into this area where
people are starting to realize that this
is an important area that needs a lot of
investment because otherwise businesses
are going to suffer because of it and
nations are going to suffer because of
it and that's i think part of the reason
that we're seeing this doubling of
um
of that exponential growth
you mentioned a couple great things like
i've noticed the the cloud evolution has
allowed a lot of businesses to sort of
transform the way that they work the way
that they offer services and products to
their consumers and we as human beings
are now more dependent on technology now
more than ever and so i always like to
say that like you know cyber security is
going to start to be seen as as a
service oriented role an honorable role
in society because we have customers who
build health care systems on our cloud
industrial systems on our cloud
you know offer all sorts of services
right and as we become more and more
dependent on technology we need to
ensure that we're also advancing the
state of how secure our infrastructure
is so that we can protect our customers
and protect people at the end of the day
so looks like we got a question from uh
from jeanette which is uh what makes
google's cloud more secure and trusted
than its competitors
um
so
google actually started um building a
lot of these security products for
itself right so google is known as a
very secure company and uh and so what
we've done recently is taken some of the
work that we have done to secure our own
corporations or our own customers like
you know beyond corp that we just saw
the demo for or recaptcha and
productized it and the vision here is
that every customer can be just as
secure as google is
but add to that this idea of innovation
that's there at google so for example
when we decided to go into the federal
space and do a fedramp certification
instead of just standing up a couple of
data centers near north virginia and
saying like let's do that let's you know
this is a set of customers let's give
them a cloud that is
compliant to their needs we decided to
make all of google cloud fedramp hi and
so now a customer in brazil
can leverage those features just as much
as a federal customer might um so i
think there's this leaning in to
the forefront of security
that we're now seeing with the trusted
partner cloud for example we had a
couple of announcements last week we had
an announcement with thales
and we're sort of saying that you can
a lot of nations want to
be able to own their own infrastructure
and their own destiny and so we're
taking the google cloud and kind of
making it available to them in a way
that they own it and they operate it and
so that's another thing that we're doing
that's kind of pushing the boundaries
and i think this is just this idea of
pushing the boundary that is
what makes google really special yeah i
think you i think you mentioned
something that's that's really important
there which is like because we own all
of our infrastructure and we've served
billions of users all around the world
through gmail through search and through
all this it's kind of a no-brainer that
we also allow enterprises and small
businesses to also now revamp the way
that they do their operations on our
cloud and on our infrastructure and so
we are able to do global changes like
that with the fedramp certification
right
where we do manage all of our
infrastructure end-to-end which is a big
big element of this it allows us to to
govern our cloud more securely more
efficiently and also to pioneer really
significant changes for our cloud and
all of our customers worldwide 100
yeah all right we got the uh the next
question which is from izumi um the
question is which operating systems does
bce support um does bce support
third-party clouds or on-premise
applications and i believe this question
would be probably best suited for marco
yeah i can answer that question so
the beauty of beyondcorp and i would
just say based on obviously the
breadth and width of our chrome browser
is that we can support any operating
system at this point so whether it's
chrome os obviously which we love and
hold near and dear to our hearts or
windows or mac os or linux or android or
ios we support all of them so your users
aren't going to be limited to a
particular operating system which is is
great especially when you are an
organization trying to enable right
enable your your employees and your
contractors
on top of that we support uh everything
from uh thick client applications right
to server based applications web-based
applications it could be you know http
tcp based protocols
there's no limit at this point in time
so
kind of the imagination is the limit
yeah i mean as as someone who probably
doesn't get as much exposure to beyond
corp and getting hands-on as i used to i
really loved your demo and so
that was super helpful and i you know
can't wait to go back and and and
re-watch it
um we've got a we've got another
question from tara um which is in the
spotlight sunil spoke a lot about
invisible security so two questions this
is two-pronged um
if if security is invisible
does that mean
that i can't change the settings or
decide what security i want
and two
does invisible security mean that
security is free
it's a great question i think i'd like
to step back and see what the problem is
right so the the problem we're trying to
solve
is that there is a alert fatigue that
we're trying to deal with right there's
uh you know most corporations can't even
look at forget about
processing about 50 of the alerts that
they get so you're starting to see all
these alerts coming in you don't look at
it and
there's a lot of work being done to
bubble up the more important alerts and
and put them in front of the uh
the sock and so forth but that still
means that they're 50 of the alerts that
you don't even look at right so um
so the idea is are there things that we
can do to prevent certain type of action
for example that might
not be kosher action and without without
creating friction in the in the business
so based on the businesses own rules are
there or policies that you can write are
there deny policies that you can write
what can we build into the platform
in a way that you're bringing down the
number of alerts and the number of
things that you need to watch and and
how do you actually guide things to
happen and so this idea of moving from
just always responding to things
to maybe
preventing things maybe
guiding people in the right direction
a great example is there was a customer
who once told me that just by
sometimes popping up a
uh a question like you know is this
something that you want to do
you'll find that a large number of
people will just not do it right and so
so you can you can there are a lot of
different ways that you can prevent
certain things from happening and that i
think is is the core to what invisible
security is about so it is based on uh
things that someone might configure and
it's based on the business logic that
that company wants to have and it's not
something that's just invisible in the
sense that you lose visibility into your
security it's invisible in that you know
there are things that you don't need to
do and they're not coming at you all the
time you know as much as possible it's
like no security person ever said that
their job is completely stressed for you
and it's easy right and so you know i
was always like to say like you know we
as humans we have we we do security in
our everyday lives right we threat model
where we leave the house we put our seat
belts on we lock the doors we've been
taught over all these years of evolution
how to be secure right some of us more
than others right and then when we get
into our digital lives on the cloud we
have to relearn all these things and
some of them we have to build into our
infrastructure so that they become part
of our background processes and some of
it comes through user enablement and
some of it comes through the amazing
products that we serve security is is
the core of how we advance
all of the amazing things that we're
doing as humans into this new world
where everything is technology driven
and whatnot
we got a question from newer
and this one's for tanisha probably i
would say tanisha what uh what
applications does bce support
thanks aman
bc supports all applications from iis to
sas to
thick client applications as well and
like marco mentioned we support http and
https in addition to tcp protocols like
ssh and rdp
awesome and i see a lot a lot of great
chat from the audience ravi joey tisha
tommy awesome thank you for engaging
um
all right cool so we got another
question
from uh
john mitch mitch at michelle
sorry if i pronounce your name wrong uh
it says can you only use the chrome
browser for bce
and then
how do you make sure the chrome browser
is in use is the approved one the chrome
browser that's in use is the approved
one not another chrome instance that
could be a man in the middle
yeah that totally makes sense so this is
kind of the beauty of context-aware
policies right
we can enforce these policies
down to the browser level versions for
example what kind of browsers are able
to access if it's a corporate managed
browser device you can wrap policies
around all of that so you can get very
very granular
and i would say the the other side of
this is we want users to be able to use
what browser they want right for
personal access i think that's great we
should continue to support that if
that's what they want and so that's what
the corporation wants but as far as
accessing corporate resources it's just
like anything else right you want to be
able to to manage it and we're not going
to necessarily just trust anything so
having a trusted chrome browser for
accessing corporate applications works
great for our customers
and it's just the best method to kind of
move forward
so yeah hopefully it answers your
question thanks marco yeah all right we
got a question from robert
and this is how is google's zero trust
model
different than other competing
hyperscalers
so
i think the zero trust model is like so
google said the zero trust model and i
think there's a the world that's
adopting the zero trust model the zero
trust model there's only one model there
isn't a google xero trust model in
someone else's zero trust model and the
zero trust model is very similar to
maybe i think an analogy is the things
that happened today as we got into the
studio um we
you know we've all been you know
vaccinated and tested multiple times in
the last week
and still when we came in we got tested
again and then we were masked and had a
shield and we were doing that up until
we were in front of the camera and as
soon as this is all done we're going to
be masked and you know um sent out right
so this idea that you have access to
something just at the time that you have
access and there's context to whether
you need access or not and where you're
coming from and what you're doing and
that should all be added into the
decision decision-making of what you are
i think
that's what is zero trust and it's great
that it was pioneered by google but
today that is a model that's being used
everywhere i think where the question
may be coming from is about the beyond
corp um enterprise and how is that
differentiated and i think the key thing
here is um
we've seen the the track record of
google in terms of keeping our employees
and our data safe through beyond corp
enterprise and we're trying to get that
out to our customers
and um
the one thing that i would like to point
out is the zero trust model isn't just
one tool it's a
it's a mindset it's a way in which we do
things and
i'm really excited about gcat the
announcement that we just made about the
cyber security action team
where we're going to be having like
these security experts and um and csos
people like phil venable available to
our customers to think through this
model and think through end to end how
they're going to actually be
implementing it and so that's that's the
exciting thing i think overall um we
have a we have we have the pioneering
product we have we have the knowledge of
zero trust
end to end we've actually implemented it
and we've proven it i love the uh
i love the analogy you put together
about covet and whatnot cause it's like
we went from traditional network century
network-centric boundaries to
identity-centric boundaries and now it's
like who are you and what's your purpose
and what are all the other factors into
why you should be performing this action
and i think one of the most amazing
things about when i first
joined google was not having to use a
vpn thing just work and i and i thought
that was that was really nice so um
we're going to go to a question from
amitabh
from ford
so the question is
how do we implement zero trust
in our org
this is a great question and i'm going
to actually throw that question to you
you're in the solutions team so let's
talk about this right you know how do we
implement zero trust in the org and i
guess it starts with beyond core but
what are all the all the factors that
you think about um i always like to say
that uh
a lot of big workload transformations in
security are not just a matter of buying
a product
and paying for a service
it takes a lot of enablement and
education from the top down and from the
bottom up we have to structurally think
about how we're going to transform the
way that we work and what implications
those have on the way that we work today
and what our pros and cons are and what
our approach is going to be and what our
strategy is going to be to sort of get
there and that strategy is going to be
augmented by people
by teams by development teams by tools
by partners so when we advise customers
and we sit down with clients and we talk
about solutions right and helping
transform elements of their business we
don't just talk about how a product can
be leveraged in your organization
because we've got product teams that can
talk about the product we talk about how
we can actually transform the business
how we can get the whole organization to
culturally transform the way that they
work and how we can get on a tangible
path to achieving a zero trust
architecture in their workforce and that
may be a multi-year strategy right and
so there's many many many different
layers to this
i agree i think there's this whole thing
about
you can think of a question
only in you know you can you can think
of a product and a particular problem
that you're trying to solve but if
you're not thinking about it end to end
like security is just as strong as the
weakest link right and so if you have a
contractor who has direct access then
you have a problem there so are you
thinking about the thing end to end
awesome awesome
and by the way big shout out to the gcat
for bringing on that security advisory
role so we got one last question here
entry i'm going to give you this last
question
which is what do you mean by shared fate
and how is that different from shared
responsibility it's a great question so
shared responsibility has
really unfortunately come to
mean
divvying up responsibilities i'm
responsible for something and you're
responsible for something else
and so that is not the the partnership
approach that google wants what we want
is to be able to say well
we're sharing the responsibility and
we're sharing the fate from that
responsibility so we're doing two things
one is we're making sure that we're
uh bringing in all the um
all the data like to you in terms of
configurations that you might have in
terms of like secure landing zone or
secure blueprints and then we also have
risk manager to quantify and then be
able to address your risk so all of that
is what shared fate is where we're
actually
being part of the process with the
customer awesome
thank you all for joining us today and
big thanks to sri tanisha and marco for
sharing their insights that's all we
have for you on the live show today be
sure to check out our great on-demand
content our live programming kicks off
tomorrow at 9 a.m pacific with our
community spotlight thanks for joining
us
[Music]
you